by the governor as a result of the covet
19 pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the judiciary committee
executive session on pending legislation
may be held
although i don't expect to do so today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in the meeting by
zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91
a the right to no law anyone who has a
problem accessing the meeting should
call two seven one three six hundred
that's two seven one three three six
hundred or email
hcs at leg dot state nh
that's hcs.state.nh.edu
in the event the public is unable to
access meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
we do have one staff member who will be
participating in the meeting today
that's jennifer four our committee
researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting will be done
by roll call vote
we'll begin by taking roll call
attendance each member must state their
whether they are present
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you during the meeting
which is required again under the right
to know law
for the record my name is ned gordon the
chair of the committee i am at my home
in bristol
and there is no one in the room with me
although my wife may enter at times
and mr clerk would you call the role
my industry
my computer
right so
vice chairman is here
in the committee room
with the clerk
representative sylvia
home alone in belmont
representative wolfer
here
representative alexander good morning
i'm here in goffstown alone
representative rice
has a conflict
representative silver
here in my home office in guildford
green
i'm here in my home office in hudson
with my wife
representative kelly
home alone with the dog and temple
representative tosh
hi i'm here in my home in merrimack um
by myself
representative trottier
good morning i'm here a long home in
belmont
representative smith
i'm in durham alone
representative burch
i'm here in west milan alone
representative hogan i'm here in durham
alone
representative dilorenzo
i'm here in my home office in new market
and uh there's no one in the room with
me my husband is around the house thank
you
welcome
representative chase
rollinsford alone yet my father-in-law
is in the house
representative kenny
good morning i am here uh in my
apartment in durham and roommates and
family members will be uh in the room
throughout the day thank you
okay
you're welcome
representative langley
good morning i'm here in manchester and
at home and my husband will be in and
out thank you
all
representative macbeth
good morning i'm in my home office in
portsmouth and i'm alone
representative page
good morning i'm in exeter uh in my home
office but with kids in the house
thank you
you're welcome
representative simpson
hello i'm here in exeter i'm by myself
now but my husband and sons may be in
the room later on in the day in and out
okay
thank you
so much
okay
our
first bill this morning is house bill 82
and uh the primary sponsor of that bill
is our own representative burch
representative burch would you like to
provide your testimony this morning
yes thank you uh mr chair
uh
the bill is hb
82 my name is paul burch i represent
cheshire one which are the towns of
walpole west milan hinsdale and
chesterfield uh and after introduction
of this
bill i would also like to move an
amendment to the bill
okay you can proceed
thank you at this time i would be moving
uh
amendment uh 0
479 h
uh
to the bill uh i sent a copy of this
around
uh to everyone yesterday
it uh changes the bill to a study
committee
and i'd like to speak to the amendment
humane
thank you
uh in order to
explain
why
a study committee is necessary and would
be a good idea on this bill i need to
give some background to the
uh the factual situation that has given
rise to it i'll be a little bit brief
about some of the history
because one of the uh speakers today
is alicia powell
who is
a part of the adams family that owns
wendyhurst farm
uh winnie hirst farm is located in in
west milan it is a uh
is somewhat of an icon in our community
west milan is a uh for those who don't
know
is a small town between uh keene and
brattleboro vermont and is in many
respects a town of small farms so we pay
attention to our small farms and we like
to keep our small farms
the issue that came up
uh that came to my attention
was that
the adams family that
has owned and run windyhurst farm for a
very long time entered into a
conservation easement
back in the 1980s
and i have
more recently been told
uh by its state government
that a particular use or two
of the land subject to the conservation
easement
is in violation and they would have to
stop doing that
they
received a letter
from stephen walker who's the director
of the conservation land stewardship
program
and i know one part of it which says
that these uses do not conform to the
definition of agriculture at the time
the conservation easement was completed
and which definition remains in effect
and i want to get back to that in a
moment
um so they they attempted to to resolve
this they ended up hiring an attorney
named gary kenyon gary kenyon contacted
the ag's office
uh it got bumped up to the next higher
level
which is a christopher aslan senior
assistant attorney general
who said
that
uh in order to respect the legislature's
authority
um the conservation land uh program
is not in position to negotiate a land
swap or any other adjustment
absent an indication that mr stewart has
secured a legislative sponsor for a
legislative solution
and um
basically said should the legislative
process be initiated clsp will work with
whitneyhurst farm and the legislature to
find a reasonable
solution
so they got a hold of me
and said they can't get anywhere their
lawyer can't get anywhere and they're
told to file a bill
so i reached out to um
sean jasper the commissioner of
agriculture and the former speaker of
the house
and talked to him about it he's familiar
with the uh
with the farm he's very supportive of
the farm and said that he had to support
the
the attorney general's office and that i
should
file a bill
so i filed this bill
and believe me
little did i know it was like stepping
on a or mowing over a hornet's nest
i've done that once i think it was
yellow jackets i don't want to do that
again
um
and that's resulted in a pile of letters
that you have received
and has resulted me in having zoom
conversations
emails phone calls with a host of
government officials and many many many
stakeholders in the
easement community boy did i not know
what i was stepping into all right
um
to put it
shortly
um
by everybody not everybody's but most
people's agreement
the easement entered into in the 1980s
along with a number of others is a
horrible easement they don't draft them
like this anymore
they've changed how they drafted and
nowadays they're much better easements
and in fact the law got changed by the
legislature after a court case i think
it was forester versus henniker
in the 1990s
uh to change the definition of
agriculture which is interesting that
the ag's office hasn't acknowledged that
yet when they wrote and said the
definition of agriculture hasn't changed
because it did
it changed by by legislative decree
so
the problem here is
is that everybody admits that
not everybody but many admit that these
early
leases the early uh easements are
problematic
but nobody wants to deal with it
and
thus we get a whole bunch of these
letters
um
conservation easements under the law can
be changed there are whole treatises
involved in that
um
there's a group called one of the
leading groups is the land trust
associate alliance
um
a quote from their uh
magazine saving land in 2014
most people in the land trust community
believe that in certain circumstances
conservation easement amendments can
strengthen land protection goals
while land trust should exercise caution
and adhere to sound practices they
should not fear entering into these
agreements with landowners to ensure
that easements would stand the test of
time the use of amendments to
conservation easements is expected to
increase
as easements age protected land changes
hands and on the ground conditions
evolve
so
there's 184 page treatise
online from the
land trust alliance on how to change
conservation easements
all right
uh but if you can't get people to sit
down and talk with you you can't make
the changes and that's what this bill
intended to happen
okay
so we all got 20 or 30 letters um i got
flooded phone calls i'm sure many of you
got calls i talked to state reps i
talked to a lot of people
and the arguments and this is why we
need a study committee the arguments
are two basically
and they are not consistent with one
another
on page one of a lot of these letters
you get the argument
conservation easements are perpetual
they are written in letters of fire on
tablets of stone and handed down from
mount sinai they shall not be changed
under any circumstances
that's page one page two is of course
you can change these amendments just go
talk to the attorney general's office
and there's policies and procedures and
methods to change these conservation
easements
those two statements cannot exist in the
same universe
and that's the problem here
is that
the word perpetual
is being made equivalent to no changes
whatsoever
and that is not how the law is developed
either generally in property law really
much else in the law
so that
i was told even by one person i said
well what if there was a drafting
mistake
what if they said 200 feet and they
meant
200 yards
nope can't change it
you know once it's done it's done
and we don't we're not interested in
changing
the uh
the letter actually
i got from the rockingham county
conservation district probably sets it
out best
our finite easement
stewardship fund is designed for defense
of these conservation easements not for
amendment requests
don't bother us with amendment requests
they take time effort money and we don't
really care
you know
more than that
so
the problem is as the west milan
conservation commission said
that
refusing to even talk about making
reasonable changes
discourages people from entering into
conservation easements
and they're not going to want to do that
if they feel like they can't even sit
down with government officials
so the purpose of having a study
committee
i understand that the bill as is written
is going to need to be revised
there are legitimate
concerns
about what it covers what it doesn't
cover
but if we can get everybody in a study
committee pointed in the same direction
maybe we can take care of those
um those early leases which are the ones
we're talking about there might be a
solution that says we can pass
legislation that only covers
leases done before the change in the
definition of of agriculture
we can do um a number of proposed
solutions but i think we need to get
everybody in the study committee and um
see what we can come up with
so
with that i thank you
thank you for your testimony today are
there questions for representative burch
one last thing if i could
and that is normally if we were in lob
i would have asked permission of the
chair to have alicia powell sit with me
as
the the person behind the bill i
couldn't do that obviously here
but i want to make sure that the chair
understands that she has a certain
presentation to give right she she has
signed up to speak and she will be
called upon representative alexander did
you have a question
um yes mr chair just more of a
procedural question are we allowed to
open up a public hearing then move
immediately move an amendment
or is that just is that just for the
exact session that that happens
i don't actually think it's a motion i
at this point in time we're not in
executive session so i'm not sure that
we're accepting motions i think the way
i viewed it was that representative
burch had presented the bill but at this
point in time
uh realizing what the outcome might be
has
indicated that he would prefer us to
adopt an amendment to make it a study
community
um so the motion in the exact session
would not be and not to pass his
amendment right away it would still be
it would be
i don't think there's a motion to act on
i guess what i'm saying is i don't think
there's a motion to act on right now
because we're not an executive session
all we have is a presentation by the
sponsor who has said that he would
prefer to have
his bill
made into a study committee and he has
proposed that amendment and somebody in
our executive session could offer that
amendment in a motion at the time
thank you
representative horgan
representative horrigan you're muted
usually that's a good thing but i'll
hear i'm unmuted um usually
this is the pretty routine thing that
happens in hearings all the time but
somebody brings the bill and that says
they're intending to offer a
an amendment sometimes amendments that
are
much more difficult to summarize in the
study committee which uh you know
something i think we all
can picture immediately when they say
we're going to the study committee
we've all seen those a million times but
we've seen okay i certainly see
sometimes much more complicated
amendments alluded to as happened with
the bill
i presented to another committee
yesterday so anyway
i just wanted to say that mr chair i
don't see anything unusual in that
thanks
thank you representative wolper
yes mr chairman uh representative first
did you submit written testimony
[Music]
uh i have a bunch of rough notes but
they're really to the substance of the
bill and since i've changed it to
[Music]
a study committee those are off the cuff
so i don't have anything to submit
thank you
thank you is there are there any other
questions for representative birch
saying none thank you for your testimony
we do have a number of people who have
signed up today to speak as i indicated
earlier
before we started the meeting
there was only one person who signed it
up in support and there were 286 people
signed up in opposition
to the bill
as as it's written
so at this point in time where it
appears to me that we're really
discussing whether or not we should have
a study
community and because we do have a
number of people who have signed up to
speak
i'm just going to limit the speakers if
they would
to speak no more than three minutes
at a time so we can get through our
hearing quickly and if the speakers
would more specifically address whether
there's a need for study i think that
would be very helpful
the first
person is the uh person who was
mentioned by representative burch and
that's alicia powell if she's available
i'm available
okay
you can hear me okay
we can okay
all right my name is alicia adams powell
and i'm speaking on behalf of my family
here at wendyhurst farm in westmoreland
we are a multi-generational dairy farm
in cheshire county we're milking about
250 cows and we have a maple sugaring
business as well as a restaurant where
we serve our maple syrup and we use our
own beef most of our farmland is
protected under an easement that we
entered into in 1988 we have a long
history of cooperation and collaboration
with many conservation agencies in our
region
we were named co-operator of the year in
2013 by the cheshire county conservation
district
this bill was written in response to our
request for help in dealing with the
matter that has come up recently and is
adversely affecting our livelihood and
future here on the farm
we received a letter from stephen walker
at the clsp in january of 2020 stating
that the use of our property to host
cruise night events was a
non-agriculture
use of conservation easement property
and therefore not allowed
cruise nights started in 2006. once a
week during the summer people come from
around the region and beyond with
classic cars and parked them to display
in our field no changes updates or
damage has happened to the land where
this takes place no fee is charged for
this event it does spark local interest
and has enhanced visitation to our sugar
house and farm over the years
the state argued that because the event
benefits our restaurant it is therefore
considered to be a commercial use of the
property wendy harris farm partnership
owns all the land in question and owns
and operates the sugar house restaurant
we first tried to handle this issue with
the help of legal counsel with
communication back and forth between the
clsp
and the state ag's office we attempted
mediation with stephen walker in the
clsp which is extremely unproductive
even in trying to understand their
perspective on this issue and why after
15 years this event has now been
disallowed we have reached out and
discussed this issue with many state and
agricultural organizations uh
commissioner of agriculture sean jasper
suggested pursuit of a legislative
solution as well as
chris aslin as you heard earlier stated
to us in a letter short of legislative
action to release the conserved property
from the public trust or to approve a
land swap the clsp has no discretion to
allow non-permitted commercial uses of
the easement
as part of the discussion with the ag's
office it had been at one point
suggested that a parcel of land that the
farm had retained for a possible
building lot which was equal in size to
the field in question could possibly be
swapped
at that point we discussed the matter
with paul burch who agreed to help us
pursue this legislative action
while this bill was written to try to
address this issue of being able to swap
an equal parcel of land in our easement
we understand that solution would be
difficult to enact without opening up
other issues related to other
conservation easements to us the bigger
issue here is in regard to land that is
under a conservation easement in the
state of new hampshire and had been
enacted prior to the state adopting an
updated definition of agritourism when
our easement was enacted in 1988
agritourism was not well defined as part
of agriculture in the state of new
hampshire the current definition of
agritourism as set forth in new
hampshire state law
reads as follows marketing shall include
agritourism which means attracting
visitors to a farm to attend events or
activities that are accessory uses to
the primary farm operation
including but not limited to being
providing provided a meal making
overnight stays enjoyment of the farm
environment education which shall be
instruction or learning about the farm's
operations or active involvement in the
activities on the farm
farming and agriculture
ms probably didn't want to kind of
yeah and if you could just address the
issue of whether or not you support the
idea of having the study committee that
would be appreciated
okay we respectfully request that people
involved in conservation agriculture and
legislative leadership in the state will
work with us to find a way to allow
older easements such as ours to
recognize and allow agritourism on our
farms while being able to uphold the
integrity of the conservation of
agricultural lands
so yes it would be great if it could be
put into a study committee so that um
you know there could be discussion about
this issue um because otherwise we're
we're not finding anyone to work with us
or help us in any way with an issue that
seems to be pretty common sense
okay
thank you thank you for your testimony
and are there any questions for ms
powell
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony today
the next person to testify is paul
dasher
hello can you hear me we can okay thank
you very much mr chairman uh my name is
paul dasher and uh i write
as a former vice president for land
conservation for the society for the
protection hampshire forest
during that time i negotiated and
oversaw the monitoring and enforcement
of hundreds of conservation easements i
also served on an expert panel of the
land trust alliance mentioned by
representative burst that developed the
national guidelines for amendments
to lent
i also served on the land trust alliance
standards advisory board
and i am the co-author of a document
entitled amending and terminating
conservation easements conforming to
state charitable trust requirements
which is used by the new hampshire
attorney general reviewing proposed
conservation easement amendments you
received a letter from myself and from
terry knowles who's the former assistant
director of the charitable trust unit of
the office attorney general
she has extensive experience with
charitable trusts of all kinds including
conservation easements defined as
charitable trust
she has advised public agencies towns
and land trusts on a wide variety of
issues related to the interpretation
enforcement and amendment of
conservation easements and she is the
co-author of the document i just
mentioned amending or terminating
conservation easements in new hampshire
uh conforming to charitable trust
requirements and as well as a law
uh review article on the experience of
new hampshire in that regard
i won't repeat what's in our letter
because i believe that substance speaks
to the substance of the idea of original
intent of the bill i'll simply say that
if there's to be a study committee i
would recommend strongly that the
committee
seek the advice of those who have been
involved in the amendment process in new
hampshire
i participated in dozens of conservation
easement amendment discussions some of
which were easy some of which were
difficult some of which were approved by
the attorney general in its review by uh
in using the document i mentioned
earlier and some of which were not
approved because they were
deemed inappropriate um
then there will be others in this uh
committee hearing who will address the
specific legislative problem with the
easement at wendyhurst farm which was
enacted through the lcip program in the
1980s
which is unique to that program
whereas other conservation easements in
this state can be amended despite the
fact that the documents are in put in
perpetuity
uh the concept of in perpetuity applies
to the fact that the easement itself
runs in perpetuity there is a
recognition today by all land
conservation organizations as well as
the irs which oversees the tax
deductibility of donated easements that
easements amendments may sometimes be
appropriate in very limited
circumstances so i will end my
discussion then i think you could read
my letter there are some very specific
details in there that we
wanted you to be aware of but i will let
others speak to other issues thank you
mr chair
sorry
thank you mr dasher for your testimony
are there any questions for mr dasher
again thank you for your testimony today
the next person to speak is christina
snyder
christine is available
and after christina will be thomas
maslin so you could just raise your hand
and we'll know how to pick you out
quickly
other shoes
no now can you hear me
oh
no
wait christine
we'd like to hear from christina snyder
first and then we'll hear from you mr
maslin thank you
go ahead ms snyder hello
hello thank you uh for having me here
today um i wanted to i'm a member of the
chester new hampshire conservation
commission and i did uh talk with uh
representative burch on the phone
i will speak to the amendment um i was
opposed to the original bill um i do
support having a study committee
to make this short i will just pick up
on a point
though for future reference
that representative burke said that
in his opening remarks
that not make not being able to make
amendments might encourage people not to
enter easements i will say that as a
member of a conservation commission i
found that to be the actual opposite
when we talk to people about making um
putting donations uh donating their land
and putting uh conservation easement on
it
one of their biggest fears is that their
wishes will be changed in the future
they have uh they enter into contract in
good faith that their wishes down the
road decades down the road will be
adhered to
and they are sometimes distrustful of
government and if a bill um the way this
original bill was written if that were
to pass i think we would actually see
less and less people inclined to donate
easements
we ourselves donate an easement to the
town and we put specific uh
specific language in there to our wishes
and if we thought that decades down the
road that language would be changed and
our wishes uh would change
and new owners would um do the opposite
of what we would like to have had happen
on to our property we would probably not
have donated the easement so when that
study committee if it does pass
i hope that that's taken into
consideration and that's all i have
thank you
thank you very much are there any
questions for ms schneider
sing none thank you for testifying today
thomas
maslin after after mr maslin will call
upon barbara richer
good morning can you hear me
we can
yes good morning my name is thomas
matsmond i'm an attorney
in concord
i have been representing landowners and
land trust and conservation easement
transactions
for over two decades
i've been involved in a number of
amendments both before
the guidelines were established by the
attorney general's office and since
we need to recognize that in new
hampshire conservation easements are
dealt with as charitable trusts
and that's an important consideration i
believe that the current system that mr
dasher explained
is working well through the guidelines
uh adopted by the charitable trust unit
of the attorney general's office
uh
which requires a robust and rigorous
review of amendment requests
based upon guidelines established in
many many studies
it works well
and i will echo also what mr dash you
said in that if a study committee is to
be formed that you reach out to those
who have been involved in conservation
easement transactions
because there's a wealth of knowledge
and information out there
easements in new hampshire can be
amended
and i think
we have a narrow situation here which
perhaps could be solved without uh
wholesale revision to our statutory
schemes thank you very much
thank you for your uh brief testimony
much appreciated are there any questions
for mr maslin
yes representative maclean
thank you mr chair just just a quick
question so um because all these uh
easements are amendable is is the
problem just with the l-chip easements
and there's something different about
those
i think there is something different
with the lcip's it's because of the
statutory scheme under which that
program was adopted
thank you as that's pre-l chip there's a
difference between the lcip and lca
lchip ah okay
any other questions for mr maslin
attorney maslan
if not
thanks for your testimony today thank
you
barbara richter and
and after we hear from
ms richter we'll hear from jack savage
okay well thank you very much for this
opportunity to provide comments on house
bill 82
my name is barbara richter and i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
association of conservation commissions
nhacc is a non-profit organization that
serves 217 conservation commissions in
the state
and we work with more than fifteen
hundred volunteers committed to
protecting natural resources in their
community
and i'd just like to point out that um
towns in new hampshire do hold
conservation easements and this bill as
written
would cause
a lot of complicated lawsuits and would
end up um
being a great legal expense for a lot of
communities and the reason why we were
opposed to this bill is mainly because
of that broad language that was included
um the including but not limited to
and
the term terminology to correct an
injustice for any reason that advances
the public good
because we have questions that you know
is it an injustice to new hampshire
citizens when taxpayer dollars have been
used to purchase an easement to then
change the terms of the easement
so there's a lot of questions regarding
that and it's not that towns are not
willing to discuss amendments or
willing to consider
landowner issues but under these broad
guidelines
it i think it would just be a legal
nightmare
so we do hope that when you are
creating the study committee that you
address these broader
issues and make sure that you are
following those guidelines
as others have pointed out but the ag
ag's office has established and in my
letter i also sent a link to those
guidelines because that process has been
working well and i think that
really keeps everybody on track and
aware of what's happening so
um
and i just like to point out just a
couple more things real quickly
that
conflict a bit with this this bill um
because
new hampshire has already determined um
natural aries to be in the public good
if you look at rsa 79a it is hereby
declared to be in the public interest to
encourage the preservation of open space
thus providing a healthful and
attractive outdoor environment
um
so
if it's already a public good you know
which public good to advance there's a
lot of questions here
and the language of this bill really
provides no parameters or legal
guidelines so it would just complicate
issues
and finally i just want to point out
that nhacc supports farms we want to
make sure that they're productive and
profitable
farms face many challenges today and
conservation easements continue to be a
source of funds to help farmers plan for
the future
income from the sale of a conservation
easement can be used to pay off farm
debt invest in equipment and reduce
mortgage or um purchase additional land
um and with this
finish up
all right
so i do um think that
having too broad of a language that the
towns will no longer want to hold
easements and you're going to be
limiting the opportunities for land
conservation for landowners so we hope
that that's taken into consideration in
the study bill we would certainly
support a study bill if that's the
direction this is heading thank you very
much and i'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you
any questions for ms richter
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and jack savage
and
jack will be followed by paul stusker
thank you mr chairman i appreciate the
opportunity to speak
you can hear me
we can
my name is jack savage i'm the president
of the society for the protection new
hampshire for us
we hold some 750 conservation easements
around the state covering about more
than 130 000 acres
and as paul dascher alluded to we were
instrumental in
making conservation easements possible
back in the 1970s
um here in new hampshire um we deal with
easements that were written back then we
deal with easements that were written
um more recently you've received a
letter from us i won't read that or
repeat that um
uh you'll have that input in writing i
did want to point out that that the bill
as proposed
addressed rsa
477-46 and
as we address this issue as a state we
want to look at rsa 162 c10 as well
which i think is something that
specifically
limits the number of changes that one of
these lcip easements
can do
and so
if if this goes to study committee i
think you need to take a broad look at
what
the existing law and whether there's an
opportunity to provide
a reasonable process for considering an
amendment of an lcip easement um the
bill of sales also has a number of
unintended consequences that
bring the irs into it and to what extent
a
donated easement
might be deductible by the irs if it's
if the ability to
amend it is too broad and without a
rigorous process
there's an issue about whether
the funding mechanisms the federal
funding agencies if if the ability to
amend is too broad would in fact
continue funding agricultural easements
that wouldn't be in the
favor of
future
farmers who are looking to make use of
this tool
and i would remind that every amendment
is based on a specific easement and you
have to look at the language in that
easement
and even if there is the ability to
amend the answer may still be no the
intent of the original easement may be
more important than a changing
definition of agriculture so it really
comes down to looking specifically
easement and answer your question we
would be in favor of a study committee
as long as it includes input from
stakeholders among the conservation
community
that deal with easement amendment issues
on a regular basis thank you very much
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for mr savage
if not again thank you for your
testimony today
paul suska and then he'll be followed by
judas bang
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee i'm paul suska from the
department of environmental services
where we have programs that fund land
conservation to protect important
resources specifically water supplies
and wetlands
des has concerns about hb 82 as
introduced
our concerns are outlined in our
testimony letter
we're not taking a position on the
amendment but we would be happy to work
with the study committee to craft a
solution
that addresses the sponsor's concerns to
the exp
to the extent possible
without harming the departments and the
state's interests in resource protection
thank you
thank you for your testimony today uh
are there any questions for mr suska
seeing none again thank you and judith
spang is judith available
yes there she is
well i learned long ago that every time
i engage in conversation with my dear
friend representative burch i better be
prepared to be fast on my feet
and once again i was not aware that he
was going to propose this amendment but
i greatly respect
the knowledge
and insight that has gone into his
decision to make this a study committee
i was going to testify as a landowner
who has conference conservation
easements and
the fact that we understand that there
are certain uses we have reserve certain
uses in our easements
we can't always look ahead to know that
the neighbor is going to want to run a
line across our our land
so that isn't accounted for and we
understand that ultimately decisions
will be allowed on our easement and what
will not
all hinge on the resource values
that both we and the
organization that are helping us want to
protect
so i don't think that you know lando can
chafe underneath
their the restrictions that they find
themselves under
but i think if the landowner keeps in
mind there was a reason that they wanted
to put this easement in there's likely
to be fewer problems
in term i've been the chair of multiple
study committees and study commissions
over my 20 years in the house
and i have one piece of
input that i like would like to make i
would like for that study to committee
to have
some parameters around which they're
going to do their work
for example
um i became very concerned with talk to
representative burch
about how farm easements are written and
as a board member of l-ship
um and having worked to get easements on
palm is i realized that this is a very
unique kind of situation where those
easements have to be different
our the easement on our 100 acres was
obtained through federal funding that's
a whole other issue
some it's through state funding some is
through private donations all of those
are specific issues
that need to be addressed and i think
that in
designing this study committee
we have to decide
which of those issues we're going to
concentrate on or how we're going to
prioritize them
in terms of what we're going to address
so we have plenty of experts that we're
going to we're hearing from now who can
help to design that study so we get the
most out of it um going forward
if you could just
wrap up your testimony that would be
appreciated
chairman gordon you got it
okay i am wrapped thank you very much
thank thank you for your testimony and
are there any questions from spang
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony today
i see i do have one person on the
attendee list with their hand up and
that's tom donovan from
the department of justice
good morning
you need to unmute there you go
um good morning my name is tom donovan
i'm the director of charitable trusts at
the attorney general's office
um and i want to just speak uh briefly i
support uh this bill going to the study
committee i think there some good could
get out of it
um
ours is the office that you've been
hearing about it's the one that reviews
proposed amendments to conservation
easements
we get about 15 to 20 such requests
every year
and you've heard from others that
you know some sometimes they go well
sometimes they don't go well but we give
each one
consideration
there are
this easement is complicated because
it's an old lcip easement
and there are two flavors of trusts
involved in this easement
one is
the public trust which is written into
the lcip statute and that easement
and that puts a restriction that the
staff at the
conservation land stewardship program
can't simply change uh an easement that
was granted using state funds under the
lcip program that's why a legislative
fix
relating to that part may be in order
uh but maybe a narrowly
a narrow bill might be able to address
it the other flavor of trust is
charitable trust
and that applies to any conservation
easement where
there was a donation in whole or in part
and most conservation easements fall
into that
and if there's a charitable trust then
you're dealing with property rights and
that's frankly not the the role of the
legislature
um
if
uh
if there is something that our office
cannot address then the uh place to go
is to uh
to a court so i don't want uh folks to
think that just a legislative fix
is going to um get windyhurst farm
is going to solve all their problems
there is a process in our office as well
that would uh be able to address the
charitable trust and i'd be happy to
answer any questions
any questions for attorney donovan
yes representative simpson
thank you mr chair thank you mr donovan
for taking my question
i something came up in an earlier
testimony and i think you might be the
right person to answer this question for
me
somewhere we were hearing in the
testimony that the um
that your office
was not able to
include the newer definition of
agriculture in your reflection on this
particular easement and i just wondered
if that was
why that why that was
yeah um representative simpson that's a
good question i i think they might be
referring to the
conservation land stewardship program
and it may be that there is specific
language in that easement
as recorded
that
might not be able to evolve with the
change in the definition of agriculture
um i haven't seen the deed so i can't
comment on it
um
but um
there's always a deed that you have to
look at um in all of these cases
thank you
that's helpful any other questions for
attorney donovan
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
and there is a one other person with
their hand up that's sheila vargas
thank you chairman uh members of the
committee i did submit written testimony
for the record my name is sheila vargas
i am speaking today on behalf of the
nature conservancy here in new hampshire
and i promise i will be brief as i i did
submit written testimony so i will touch
on just a couple of of facets and i will
speak to the study committee as well so
um just so you are all aware since 1961
the nature conservancy in new hampshire
has worked with both partners and
landowners to protect more than 294
thousand acres in new hampshire and um
just to keep it brief you have all heard
um the reasons why this bill is a bad
bill and we certainly oppose the bill as
originally intended we also opposed the
study committee um and our reasoning
behind that is just the office of the
attorney general already has a clear and
well-established process to amend
easements when complications arise and
that is all i have for all of you today
so i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you for your brief testimony it's
appreciated are there any questions for
ms vargas
seeing none
again thank you for your testimony today
okay i just uh one more hand go up we're
way overdue on this hearing uh and that
hand is matt
leahy uh good morning mr chairman i'll
be briefer just a quick question will
the language in that um
amendment be posted online so we can
see it
uh
representative birch is that amendment
available for people to view the
amendment is available and if mr leahy
wants to shoot me an email i'll send him
a copy great thank you
[Music]
and i see no other hands up and so i'll
declare the hearing on house bill 82
closed
and we will move on to our next item of
business today which is house bill 83
also sponsored by
our committee mate
representative burch
and representative burch are you
prepared to introduce that bill today
you had to have to unmute yourself first
representative birch can you hear us
you need to unmute
yeah i thought i had unmuted i guess i
didn't all right i can hear you fine can
you hear me
can you hear me
yeah we can hear you now
okay
uh again my name is paul burch i
represent cheshire one of the towns of
west milan
walpole chesterfield in hinsdale
um i would like to introduce to the
committee hb 83
which would prohibit
non-disparagement clauses in settlement
agreements involving a governmental unit
and i would note i believe there's
a
small
amendment that has been filed which i
don't seem to have in front of me
which would uh
uh
change the language to simply
have it as a claim
by
or against the government so it goes in
both directions
and with that i'd like to speak to the
bill with the minor amendment
yep go ahead
thank you
um basically what this bill does
is
says that if there's a settlement
of a claim involving a government body
that settlement cannot include a clause
that prohibits the party from discussing
the facts of the claim or speaking
negatively about each other
this bill does not apply
to public to private suits which do not
involve government actors and i think if
you look at the uh
at two chairs versus three chairs you'll
understand a little better what this
bill is about
if
if i crash my car into a neighbor's car
and
she sues me
that's
two people involved in a lawsuit we
reach an agreement we can have whatever
terms we like uh in terms of how we
settle it you can look at it as two
chairs one's my neighbor one's me we
resolve our suit
what this bill deals with are three
chairs
and these are suits involving the
government and the third chair
basically is that of the public
and if we understand that there's three
chairs at the table we'll understand
some of the conversation about this bill
better
there's already a statute we have that
requires the terms of the settlement
to be a public record
but that's been a very little use if the
parties cannot talk about what actually
happened
why this bill
a little while ago actually by now a
couple years ago i was reading an
article and i think it was a concord
monitor i'm not sure
um that
related how a reporter was trying to do
an article about a number of fairly
large settlements involving misconduct
at one of our county jails
and the reporter went
from one
plaintiff or victim to another to
another
and it kept being told i would like to
talk to you about what happened to me
we'd like to talk to you about what
happened to our family member
but if we say a word we're going to lose
our settlement
and
that's a problem it's a national problem
and it's a problem here
in uh in new hampshire this is a
similar bill it might be identical bill
that was passed by the house
in the past term by voice vote
in the u.s
civil trials are disappearing
instead of litigating disputes in court
parties have increasingly turned to
settlements and other avenues of dispute
resolution
one result of this credit is this is
that systemic discrimination
and other harms that might have been
revealed to the public
in public trials have been obscured
through sealed settlements
and non-disparagement provisions
such provisions are not uncommon
in baltimore because it was a big case
in baltimore which i will mention
baltimore has inserted non-disparagement
clauses in 95 percent
of recent settlement agreements
with plaintiffs that have alleged police
misconduct 95 percent
the victims cannot talk about what
happened to them at a risk of losing
their settlement
one of the core values of the first
amendment
is to promote public understanding
through free speech
of the workings of our government
as the supreme court noted in lane
versus frank
speech by citizens on matters of public
concern lies at the heart of the first
amendment which was fashioned to ensure
unfettered exchange of ideas for the
bringing about a political and social
changes desired by the people
we've made it clear that the core first
amendment concern
is the actual workings not just the
speeches reports and handouts of our
public bodies
in 2019
in over b versus mayor of baltimore
the fourth circuit found that the first
amendment prohibited the enforcement of
a settlement agreement between the civil
rights plaintiff and the city of
baltimore based on these first amendment
core values it was a suit brought by the
aclu
and the court noted
that it wanted
it it didn't approve
of the government using its power to
curb speech not to its liking
and
uh that is uh
why
this litigation exists
we will hear
and you may have read there's an
objection saying this is going to
increase the cost of litigation
uh somehow that if
if
you can't have secret settlements cost
litigation is going to go up
that's been widely discredited
it's promoted but it's widely
discredited
first of all from the courts have
discredited that
from the oberbee case
we are troubled by the underlying logic
of this assertion police misconduct
claimants get money to keep quiet the
city gets silence and expedient
litigation and everybody wins except
presumably members of the public who are
interested in transparency surrounding
police misconduct suits
aside from that concern they're two
factors that make the city's assertion
unconvincing
first the assertion is overly simple
the outcome of settlements and
negotiations
in a police misconduct suit is likely to
be driven by complex interactions
case-specific factors
such as the defendant's risk of exposure
to high damages the claims financial
resources besides appetite for for
litigation
therefore we will not assume that the
financial
terms of future settlement will be
affected by the enforceability of
non-disparagement agreements
okay
i will
note that a scholarly study compared
the uh the costs of the
settlements in
states that have this versus the
settlement in the case states that don't
found no appreciable difference
and um
i know we're falling behind so i will
end my comments at that point at this
point thank you are there any questions
for representative burch
representative d lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative birth for taking my
question
so
is a non-disclosure stipulation
essentially a gag order
and in many respects it is
it we're talking here only about
the uh
ability to talk about the case and just
quote disparage the other side and it
does operate as a gag order yes
other
questions for representative burch
representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
if this was uh changed and people were
able to talk do you think that's going
to affect the settlements
probably
not
um
i did settlements
in in in the world of of criminal
prosecution
and criminal cases
all of those cases are public
and
of those cases are resolved in by
negotiation about five percent go to
trial 95 are negotiated in the light of
day
and those negotiations go on rapidly
they go on quickly they go on every day
in in every court pretty much in the
united states that handles criminal
cases so the idea that you have to have
cases done in secret in order to achieve
settlement just you know just isn't true
okay
thank you
representative alexander
um thank you mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um so you talked
about the um the cost of litigation
argument increase argument is
discredited um you mentioned a little
bit about like earlier settlement do you
think that this bill would prevent an
earlier settlement
from both parties
no
people settle for a number of reasons
um
and uh
cases tend to go to trial if there's a
dispute about facts or dispute about law
if there isn't you know then people will
tend to to reach what best best
agreement they can reach
um
the speed of settlement often depends on
the court how fast the court pushes it
along forces uh
uh
decisions made at the courthouse door
and things like that
yes thank you
representative mclean
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question so
um you mentioned that um other states
are already going down this path
so
how broad is that are we talking lots of
states and how long is this is this a
relatively new thing or has it been
going on for quite some time
it's been going on quite some time i
don't have the numbers there there are
some experts that may be testifying
later
uh in this hearing that may have more
information than i do
uh about the breadth of it uh so i don't
have that information it is uh
um
non-disclosure agreements non-uh
disparagement agreements
are obviously
much in the news in the last couple of
years
um
be careful about making representations
about our former president's use of
non-disclosure agreements but they are
as the city of baltimore noted they're
incredibly common
in uh settling misconduct litigation
problem is is if you want to do a study
of police misconduct or correctional
officer misconduct or school counsel or
misconduct and if all the cases are
sealed and nobody can talk about them
then there's no way for the public
to be able to do public policy to deal
with those issues
because the information is no longer
available it's not available to the
public
so just a quick follow-up mr care yes
you mentioned that the impact on access
has been widely discredited and and your
site the case
are you is there empirical evidence
in those jurisdictions where this has
happened that has actually shown that
now we haven't really seen a drop in
access or are people coming after you're
going to speak to that
um
there is
a scholarly study by richard
zitrin i can send you the site if you
wish
it's called the case against secret
settlements or what you don't know can
hurt you
in the institute for study of legal
ethics in 1999
and uh that's where it noted that states
with anti-secrecy regulations have not
seen a decrease in settlements
and that parties who don't want their
conduct exposed will still have a
substantial incentive to settle before
the heightened scrutiny of a trial
thank you
you're welcome representative silver
mr sharer thank you representative for
taking my question
can you explain the rationale of why
taxpayer money should be used to settle
a dispute over
governmental actions
that should be kept secret from the
public who's paying the bill
uh no i cannot i think that's why
there's three chairs at the table
um when you're talking about not only
spending public money
and trying to hide
the reasons for it but you're also
talking about the behavior of public
employees
and uh who are
uh employees of of every one of us and
we can't tell if they're doing a good
job or not a good job
if these settlements are quiet what has
happened in some
areas and this has happened in new
hampshire
is that for instance a police officer
who
does an act of misconduct
and there's a settlement of the
misconduct case with secrecy the officer
is allowed to quietly resign and the
officer goes to the next town over and
gets hired
and uh repeats bad behavior
and that is unfortunately that happens i
think that's called the hot potato issue
thank you are there any other questions
for representative birch
seeing none
thank you for your testimony today
again
and call upon cordell johnston
thank you mr chairman uh cordell
johnston representing the new hampshire
municipal association in opposition to
this bill
um as representative burch mentioned the
house did pass an identical bill two
years ago
the senate unanimously killed that on a
voice vote
uh when it when it got the bill and i
think for for pretty good reason
um
as representative burch mentioned in
these in these situations uh there are i
guess theoretically three seats at the
table
uh one is the public but the other two
seats
i don't think can be
ignored
um parties to a lawsuit should have a
right to negotiate
their settlement terms
and we don't believe that the state
should be interfering with uh that right
um
representative burch talked about
uh police misconduct cases and i think
almost
almost everything you mentioned was
about police misconduct cases but this
would apply to any um
any lawsuit between a
government entity any lawsuit involving
a government entity and and
police misconduct cases are going to be
a very small fraction of all of those
cases they're going to be all kinds of
employment um employment
litigation and other things um
i think it is common sense that it will
make it harder to to settle lawsuits
um
parties negotiate
settlement agreements um
and there are various incentives to
settle and this takes away
a very important uh a very important
incentive
uh one of the things that
needs to be kept in mind is that
in
many if not most of these cases
um
the settlement is going to be discussed
and and much of the case is going to be
discussed by a
board of selectmen or a
school board or a city council in a
non-public session
for obvious reasons
um
the minutes of those sessions will
almost invariably be sealed to protect
um
to protect privacy and also to
protect
discussions involving litigation
those
if those minutes are sealed and
legally so
members of that public body are there
after prohibited from talking about
anything that went on in in non-public
section
but the other party is not prohibited
from talking about it
so that leaves a situation where the
employee former employee
or the
person whoever it is who brought the
lawsuit is now perfectly free to
say whatever he or she wants
about what went on and whatever they
want
about the
public officials but the public
officials are
now the ones that are subject to a gag
order
and that is a problem
so um
for those reasons
we oppose the bill i know you have
written testimony from other at least
one other organization opposing it for
similar reasons and i'll end my
testimony there thank you
thank you mr johnson and representative
smith did you have a question
yes thank you very much um
mr chair um mr johnson can you explain
to me um
why
the public
in a state that
values the concept of right to know
should not
know
about
what happened in these negotiations
i know that the municipal association
um tends to see itself as
playing the role of protecting
the town
governments and city governments
but
since they those governments are there
at the behest of the citizens who
elected them
why shouldn't the citizens have access
to
the details of these negotiations
the
um
first of all it's not real it's not
the details of the negotiations
that would be that are prohibited by a
non-disparagement agreement
what is prohibited is
either party
from uh
making negative comments
about the other party so it's not the
it's not the um
it's not the negotiations the the
negotiations are
done in private but that's a that's a
separate issue that's not this bill
that's that's the the right to know law
i suppose if you want to
if you want to address that through the
right to know law although we would have
you would have concerns about that too
um what the non-disparaging agreement is
simply
it limits what one party can say about
the other party
and
as i said i acknowledge that there is a
third seat at the table the public has
an interest
but um
employees uh have a privacy interest
um
police where who are accused of
misconduct have a privacy interest
um
and so there there are a number of
interests at stake
i don't i don't think it's
as easy as saying just the public has a
right to know and
everything should be open to the public
thank you i won't belabor this now thank
you
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
johnson for taking our attorney johnson
mike question
i just wanted to verify what you said
about
if we've got the three people at the
table or the three chairs
and there's a non-public hearing and
those minutes are sealed
did you say that the person say the
public person is able to talk about it
but the other the people that are under
the non-disclosure have to keep their
mouths quiet
what i'm saying is um
setting aside a non-disparagement
agreement
if i'm
if i'm the person who has sued the town
or have been sued by the town
and there is a
uh
there's a discussion in non-public
session
uh among say the board of selectmen
um and then the minutes of that
non-public session are sealed
they are the
the members of the public body the board
of selectmen in this case are prohibited
from revealing
what occurred in that non-public section
and if they do they're subject to
removal from office under rsa i think
it's 42 colon 1a
but i if if i the
employee or the the person who is uh
on the other side of the lawsuit if i
reveal what happened in in non-public
session
there's no i've done nothing wrong i
have a perfect i have a perfect right to
do that
unless
there is a non-disparagement agreement
that prohibits me from doing that
okay
i thank you that was the piece i missed
thank you very much sure thank you
any other questions for mr johnston
zing none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
and the only other
the only other person who pre-registered
to speak today is a robert mcnamara from
arlington virginia
and is mr mcnamara available
see
updates
thank you mr chair can you hear me
we can
thank you my name is robert mcnamara i'm
a senior attorney with a non-profit law
firm called the institute for justice
here in arlington virginia where we've
done a lot of work on the first
amendment implications of these sorts of
gag orders and we're actually currently
engaged in litigation against the
securities and exchange commission about
whether these sorts of gag orders
violate the constitution i'm here to
speak in favor of the bill which i think
is wise both as a matter of policy and
as a matter of law i think the the best
way to understand the policy argument
here
is to imagine a lawsuit where the
government settles for fifty thousand
dollars plus a non-disparagement clause
and i think there are only two things
that could be going on in that lawsuit
either the fair settlement value of the
lawsuit was actually less than fifty
thousand dollars and the government
defendant is paying out extra taxpayer
dollars in order to
pay the private citizen not to speak out
on a matter of public concern whether
it's
don't go telling people that our police
department engaged in misconduct or
don't go telling people that we do a bad
job clearing the ice in the parking lot
they're paying taxpayer dollars to buy a
private citizen's silence but i think
the alternative is actually worse the
alternative in that case is the fair
settlement value of that case actually
was 50 000
and the government is withholding the
fair payment in an effort to coerce the
private citizen
into agreeing to give up their basic
first amendment right to criticize the
government
um either way i think that's deeply
troublesome and it's even more
troublesome in a context where the
government brings the suit itself brings
the full coercive apparatus of the state
and says we'll go away but we'll go away
if and only if you promise not to say
bad things about us uh it is i think
inherently dangerous when the government
uh uses its power to coerce private
citizens not to say bad things about
that very government uh but i also think
going to the
the question of whether this bill would
increase litigation costs i think it's
actually quite the opposite uh because
one other thing that emerged in the the
2019 fourth circuit case that
representative burch mentioned is the
fourth circuit didn't just find that
agreements like this can violate the
first amendment and actually found that
the news media can bring lawsuits on its
own bring its own first amendment
challenges to policies of including
provisions like this in settlement
agreements so one of the plaintiffs in
that case was just a local newspaper
suing the city of baltimore and so too
the concord monitor reporter that
representative burch mentioned would be
able to bring his own lawsuit and say it
violates the first amendment when you
insert these agreements in settlement
agreements
and so it's not just the question of
whether settlement agreements increase
or decrease the difficulty of settling
the case in which the gag order is being
entered
allowing government entities to demand
gag orders like these in new hampshire
will actually lead to brand new
litigation whole new lawsuits first
amendment challenges that could be
avoided if the policy embodied by this
bill were in place
with that i thank you very much for your
time and the opportunity to testify and
i'm happy to answer any questions
representative macbeth
thank you mr chair and and thank you for
uh taking my question um attorney
mcnamara i'm just wondering um is the
non-disparagement
is that defined in within the statute or
is there um significant um case law that
lets people exactly know what that what
is included in that um
phrase
thank you i i think the the fair
definition of a non-disparagement
agreement uh is an an agreement that
prevents
um
that quite simply prevents a party from
saying a bad thing about another party
from disputing the facts of the
underlying case uh and i think that is
the the heart of the bill it's not about
uh the ability to disclose the ins and
outs of particular negotiations and who
offered what what these clauses are used
for
uh is preventing the
either party from going out in public
and saying what the government did to me
was really bad uh or the government
going out and saying that person's lying
we didn't really do something that was
very bad to them that's how
non-disparagement clauses are used in
private litigation but in public
litigation the the basic right to say
what the government did to me was really
bad and the right of the government to
put out its own press releases and say
what we did wasn't really bad is is the
heart of how we engage in
self-government in this country and
agreements not to disparage the
government uh are agreements not to
engage in fundamental political
discourse and that's why they're
appropriate with purely private
litigation but are deeply dangerous when
it comes to public defendants
thank you very much
are there other questions
i think mr mcnamara if i could it seems
to me that
having practiced and
drafted settlement agreements
i
and including despair and
non-disparagement clauses
the idea as an attorney is that
you don't want to continue litigating an
event
after
after you've settled and just settling
it for money doesn't necessarily settle
the dispute
if the one of the parties can still
actively contest the facts
so
there's certainly an advantage to having
the non-disparagement provision
in the in your settlement agreement
because
in fact that's what settles the case
but the other side of it is that
that because and i think it's the
three-chair issue that is because a
government entity is working on behalf
of the people that the people have a
right to know so it seems to me that our
decision today is a decision as to
whether we think the people's right to
know
has
imbalance a greater value
than
fully settling a case
so i think you're absolutely right mr
chair that that's the value of clauses
like this for private citizens where you
can say i just never want to talk about
this car accident again i don't think it
was my fault but i want to give you five
thousand dollars in exchange for just
never ever talking about this again but
i think framing the impulse that way
illustrates why it's an unacceptable
impulse for government the government
doesn't get to say
i just never ever want to talk about
this police misconduct case again i just
never ever want to talk about whether
we're doing a good job at road
maintenance again
because the public debate about what
happened in the past is in part the
public debate about how we're going to
prevent things like this from happening
in the future and it's just not i think
a permissible impulse for the government
in a free society to say we should just
never discuss this incident again uh the
people who decide whether or not they
care about that incident are the voters
and they're not the government as
litigants saying we're done with this
and moving on
thank you
are there other questions
for mr mcnamara
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
thank you sir thank you to the committee
those are all the people who
pre-registered to speak today is there
anybody else who wishes to testify
i have one person who apparently is on
the telephone who wishes to testify
yes are you there you have to unmute
uh thank you i'm unmuted i'm on a
speakerphone can you hear me clearly
yeah if you could identify yourself that
would be helpful
yes good morning mr chairman members of
the committee my name is lisa marie
mulkern
i am the former programs information
officer of the new hampshire veterans
home in tilton new hampshire
i served as a programs information
officer from
2002 to 2006.
i have previously testified so i will
not go into much detail about what
happened to me
i would like to give specific reference
to the testimonies on file with the new
hampshire state house
particularly house bills
and house bill 591
they both were
uh
dealing with um
legislating for the
status flying protection
of
harassment in the workplace
i am very much
in favor
of this legislation
and my testimony
i specifically wanted to go last so that
i could speak
and not
reiterate anything that the other
speakers have already spoken about
um in my case
we are keeping the testimony to three
minutes so if you could yeah
okay
i would like i would i would like to
tell you that i was terminated from my
position
at the home
and this is about
forcing the government to bear the
burden of proof
i
was not given the opportunity to
have my appeal publicly heard before the
personnel appeals board
in fact a pre-hearing trial at the
was put into
non-public session when it should not
have been
i settled my case
for no more than anything that i would
have been awarded
had i
gotten the opportunity which i should
have gotten to appeal before to appear
before the personnel appeals board and
have this all heard in public
they told me not to bring the case to
them it was the worst case they had ever
seen and to simply go settle it don't
even think about bringing it to us
and you attorney gordon at that time
you may recall that you were the sitting
judge in franklin district court
part of what was done to me in my
termination i left the home in handcuffs
and was charged with criminal trespass
there is no gag order in my settlement
agreement it was the only thing that i
wanted out of my settlement agreement
so that i could speak about it
i have disclosed the entire contents of
my personnel file
in
testimony on house bill 591
you should be able to find that on file
i can find it by googling my name
a direct link to it lisa marie mulkern
i needed someone to act
years ago
there are 36 dead veterans at the home
as a result of this coveted virus
it didn't have to happen
i am urging all of the members of the
committee today to do the right thing to
act and to pass this legislation thank
you
thank you for your testimony today
representative horrigan
do you have a question
you have to unmute representative oregon
yep
oh sorry about that just um
looking what year were those hp 1403 and
hb 591
i believe that hb
was
january of 2010.
all right
and uh hb 591
that went for a while
i think it was finally um
it did not succeed because it was not
able to be overturned by the veto of the
governor
i think that was the result of that was
in 2014
okay
um it was specifically to provide status
blind protection from harassment
now
those were the only avenues that i could
find although i have
gotten
some
minimal press coverage certainly not in
the state of new hampshire
none of the press would touch my case
nobody would come near it nobody would
talk
uh i did get some national press on the
issue you can find that as well
oh thanks yeah
and uh
we all agree that the 36 deaths um the
veterans were a tragedy although we'll
say we have one member no they're not a
tragedy that was a preventable
circumstance as was the global situation
at hand right now
i have never taken an oath to defend or
uphold the constitution
i know where the duty of we the people
rests
and it rests in the first amendment
and the second amendment is there to
defend the first
i understand we have a one member who's
not a member of his committees he's not
here but
a tireless defender of both veterans and
the second amendment and he
or whatever is worth um must be aware of
the veterans home and i rely on him to
alert us about it he's uttered not a
peep about it but that said uh mr
chairman the 36th member
thank you mr chairman could you spell
your name for me lisa murray
yes it's lisa marie l-i-s-a
hyphen marie m-a-r-i-e
my last name is amazon mary
u-l-k-e-r-n is in nancy
thank you
are there any questions from his mother
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
and is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
i see no other hands and i'll declare
the hearing on house bill 83
closed
and
we
only have one other bill to hear this
morning and do you want to take a
10-minute break
um
like to continue
what's your pleasure
i'm flexible so
you know people need a break people need
to worry
we we have quite a few people who are
going to testify on our next bill which
is um hospital 111 so
i i think if we we just took like a
five-minute break that would be great
for everybody um just to take a brief
break so i'm gonna declare us in recess
for five minutes
thanks
all
right yeah
okay
all right
this one here is going to be
how many people are signed up on 111
wow
police association
who's this morning
uh
about public officials being dead by
some rsa
we're muted up front but that's okay
the same thing i don't know
i i i i think
so
three years
i'll call the judiciary committee house
judiciary committee back to order
our
third bill this morning
hospital this morning is house bill 111
also sponsored by
our
mini-mate
representative burch representative
burch would you like to provide your
testimony
yes thank you mr chair and
greetings again uh fellow members of
house judiciary
my name is paul burch and i still
represent cheshire one uh the
connecticut river towns of west milan
walpole hinsdale and chesterfield at
this point i am introducing h b
111 an act establishing a cause of
action against the state to protect
individual rights
and with the chair's permission i'd like
to speak uh to that bill
you may
thank you mr chair
um
this bill
uh
involves uh ending what's called
qualified immunity
what is qualified immunity
qualified immunity shields government
officials from damages
liability even if they have violated
plaintiffs constitutional rights
so long as they have not violated
clearly established law
and the courts have said that except in
extraordinary circumstances
the law is quote clearly established
unquote
only if a prior case has declared the
conduct unconstitutional
and that prior case must have facts that
map neatly onto the facts of the
plaintiff's case
it's not enough just to point to
general supreme court cases or other
cases that set out frameworks
processing the constitutionality of the
use of force
you have to show specific holdings of
specific cases
to find a factually similar case is a
challenge on its own
given the unending number of ways
government officials
can violate people's constitutional
rights
qualified immunity
is was invented by the courts
your so-called judicial activism
was invented by the supreme court back
in 1967 not by the legislatures
and it's been an abject failure
it protects officers who have
outrageously
abused their power simply because no
prior decision has declared that exact
specific conduct unconstitutional
this immunity goes against deeply held
new hampshire values
the citizens are entitled to redress of
their wrongs
through the legal process
that
is enshrined in the new hampshire
constitution
in fact this judiciary committee has
historically
stood for the principle that the doors
of our courts
are to be open to our citizens
for redress of wrongs committed by
government agents
i further want to note that this
doctrine of qualified immunity has been
criticized because it rewards poor
training of police officers
the doctrine seeks to shield police
officers from damages
liability unless they had
fair warning
or fair notice
of the unlawfulness of their acts but if
they've been poorly trained
or not trained in what the law is
then it becomes easy to say that they
had no fair warning or fair notice
so bad training or no training becomes
rewarded and that's not a good thing
it's often asserted perhaps wrongly
that this immunity is required because
police have to make split split level
decisions split second decisions
and should not be impoverished
because they make a wrong decision
let's examine briefly both premises
doctors make split-second decisions
they don't have qualified immunity
lawyers make
second decisions
they have no such immunity i could go on
no one should have immunity if they act
under color of law
and violate the constitutional rights of
citizens
they must be held accountable
as to the second issue
and that's what's really different about
this bill
this bill removes
the financial penalty against individual
government officials
period
the individual himself or herself
will not be held financially liable
under this statute
when an individual is sued the state or
its political subdivisions
are responsible for the actions of its
employees
and will pay for any damages resulting
in the proven wrongful acts of its
employees
but the bottom line is
that the employee is held financially
harmless
of course the employer can still take
whatever lawful and appropriate measures
it wishes against the employee
as per the employment contract
union rules state or municipal law or
whatever
so basically in conclusion this bill
splits the difference
it allows our citizens to seek redress
in the courts
for violation of constitutional rights
and it protects individual offenders
from financial penalty
apportioning those costs to the entity
that hired the individual
it puts a premium on effective training
of government employees so that they
don't violate
constitutional rights of citizens
and encourages the state of new
hampshire and political subdivisions
to be vigilant in not employing people
who have or might have a tendency to
violate the rights of citizens
all in all a win-win
all the way for good government thank
you
questions for representative burch
representative burch who who has the
immunity is it the governmental entity
that has the qualified immunity or is it
the individual employee
far as i know and i think others will
will be more expert on this deny it's
the government employee at the current
currently
the employee i think could be suits
personally
representative silver
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question if
this passes wouldn't the government
agencies be covered by insurance just
and so they wouldn't be out of pocket
normally i would say yes there's a fair
amount in new hampshire of self
insurance by
towns and municipalities but yes i i
suspect a uh
percentage i don't know how large a
percentage of these costs would be
covered by
insurance
um
the
the purpose here is to make sure it
doesn't come out of the pocket of the
individual
offender
thank you
okay other questions for representative
burch
see no none thank you for your testimony
we have several people who have asked to
speak today what we'll try to do is to
hold everyone as best we can to uh three
minutes
the next
person to speak is jill's bissonnette
he's available
thank you can i be heard mr chairman you
can we hearing you right now thank you
so much can i be seen as well i am
wearing a suit for the record um
uh thank you mr chairman that's a lot to
ask
i know especially for me uh thank you mr
chairman my name is jill bisonette i'm a
legal director for the aclu
of new hampshire
i'm here to testify in support of the
concept behind hb
the aclu is historically supported the
end of the doctrine called qualified
immunity that immunizes police officers
from liability uh even when there's been
a constitutional violation the bill does
two things that i just want to flag
for the committee
first is
this bill would actually create a cause
of action for damages
when a state or local police officer
violates the new hom the new hampshire
constitution and in so doing causes harm
to a person and why i think that's
important
is because currently if a state
or local police officer violates the new
hampshire constitution and as a result
causes damage to a person there's
actually no recognized
cause of action to seek damages in the
courts for that violation of the new
hampshire constitution so this
legislation would actually remedy this
problem and i think in so doing
would make local police departments
and police officers more accountable to
granite staters under the new hampshire
constitution and also into doing i think
would build greater public trust because
after all
you know what good are the independent
protections of the new hampshire
constitution if someone can't sue for
damages when
these protections are violated and
damages caused so that's the first point
i just wanted to to raise
and second as representative burch noted
in creating this cause of action this
bill would eliminate qualified immunity
as a defense to uh to this cause of
action
you know a public distrust of law
enforcement really could be attributed
to a single thing i think it likely
would be just how common it is for
an officer to evade uh legal
accountability for violating someone's
constitutional rights particularly in
cases where where forced is used
this policy that um you know really at
the end of the day prevents officers
from being held individually accountable
um it you know it exists in new
hampshire this doctrine applies
nationwide and i believe that the public
really has a difficult time believing
that law enforcement is committed to
accountability when its members are
shielded from individual accountability
even when they violate a person's
rights so what's the end result
of this doctrine
individuals who are the subject of
constitutional violations are not
compensated that's a big deal that's a
huge trade-off
in the system that we currently have
where qualified immunity operates and i
think an additional trade-off is that
the appropriate incentives may not uh
exist
because of this doctrine
you know to encourage uh full and
complete compliance with state
constitutional rights
so we don't believe qualified immunity
should exist as a defense for civil
rights violations committed by the
police and again this bill would address
this i want to be clear though by
eliminating qualified immunity
an officer you know i will still uh have
uh his or her day in court um you know
to argue that no constitutional
violation occurred the problem with
qualified immunity is it really shuts
the door on plaintiffs where ultimately
there may be a finding down the line
that there was actually a constitutional
violation so that again is the real
concern we have and the significant
trade-offs that exist with respect to
the qualified immunity doctrine as it
exists under
uh
under the law here in new hampshire so
with that i'll conclude my testimony
thank you mr chairman can i be happy to
any questions for
mr bissonnette
seeing none thank you for your testimony
uh the next person uh signed up is mark
morrison
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
okay
we can hear you all right perfect
uh good morning um mr chairman and
fellow committee members my name is mark
morrison i am a lieutenant with the
londonderry police department and i've
been a certified law enforcement officer
for over 22 years
but i speak to you today in my capacity
as the president of the new hampshire
police association in opposition to this
bill
and i would urge every member to vote
this bill is inexpedient to legislate
this past year i was privileged to be
named to the governor sununu's
commission on law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency
you have no doubt heard a lot about this
commission and the months-long effort it
involved coming up with recommendations
to further improve
what is already a great product for new
hampshire citizens that of new hampshire
law enforcement
during those months of testimony we had
people testify on the topic of qualified
and official immunity
to include some very talented folks who
would see a windfall in clients should
the law change
we also heard how devastating to the
function
of not just law enforcement but to the
overall ability of our government to
govern that these changes
be
the result from the the leak commission
on this issue
was the responsible one
which was to reject the suggestions to
change the immunity laws and make no
recommendation to modify the law
this bill should be rejected in the very
same way
today there is currently an adequate
remedy at law for cases where government
employees act in a reckless or wanton
manner while making discretionary
decisions
if employees are found to have performed
their job in that reckless or wonton
manner while making discretionary
decisions
they are not entitled to qualified or
official immunity
this standard which is a sensible one
must remain intact
to protect those who put their lives at
risk every day for the public
while still allowing for the rare worst
case scenario to be addressed with
litigation
if any changes to this body of law are
made the difficulties that we face as a
profession
to recruit and retain officers will be
exponentially exacerbated
it has been said many times that we as
officers are willing to put our lives on
the line to protect and serve complete
strangers
people we have never met and may never
meet again for the good of our
communities
what we are not willing to do however is
to traumatize our families with economic
risk
they already go through enough
this legislation have passed will harm
our state in a way
few other legislative decisions could
the paralysis that would lay siege to
local city and state governments as they
are forced to hold all their business in
order to respond to what will surely be
a flood of litigation would be
substantial
any decision that is of a discretionary
nature will be open to litigation
this will harm every regular citizen of
our state by necessitating tax increases
to deal with frivolous litigation
that will make trial lawyers very rich
while at the same time
discourage anyone from serving in a
government job
i i would like to briefly respond to a
couple of things that were said
first i appreciate representative
welch's sentiments that more training is
needed
and law enforcement is always open to
that
as you can see from the recommendations
with leak
our job essentially involves violation
of people's rights every time we seize
something or arrest somebody
it's a constitutional violation but it's
permissible by what our job is
so
the split second decisions that we make
are made during life-threatening
circumstances
in low lighting in the rain
under physical stress
flashing lights dealing with knives guns
fists and any other weapons
known or unknown
i really don't know that a fair
comparison can be made
to
you know an attorney making a split
second decision or a doctor and
doctors i don't think are normally
criminally charged with assault you know
for making a mistake during surgery
so i know time is short and there are
other speakers to hear so i'll simply
leave you with the position that nhpa is
in strict opposition to this bill
and thank you for your time and
attention
thank you mr morrison and representative
smith do you have a question
uh yes thank you uh very much mr chair
and thank you mr morrison for being
willing to answer um
questions i do have a couple of
questions for you and i don't expect you
to be able to answer them right now
i'm sure you'll have to do a little
research but i was quite taken by the
strength of your testimony and so i
would like to have the documentation
that shows
windfalls
uh in
to in in more clients flood of
litigation
tax increases
um and um i'd also like to know the um
the number of specific cases where
knives guns
and darkness of night were involved in
bringing you
to
state as facts
all those things that you did i don't
expect you to answer now but if you
could get back to us um
soon i'd really appreciate it
thank you representative smith i'll be
happy to get some of that for you
and my comments are
meant to
articulate
what situations we do make
those decisions in
that is not every decision made in
exactly that scenario but those are
exactly the types of conditions that you
can find
officers making these split-second
decisions i'm not quite sure there needs
to be more documentation on that the the
flood of litigation that
i referred to
is simply
right now
with the protections of qualified
immunity or official immunity
the lawsuits need to be disposed of as
early as possible in the legal
situation
you know when it when they're filed
if that isn't there
there will no doubt be more hearings
there will no doubt be more people that
will have the ability to bring
lawsuits for any
discretionary decision made not just by
police officers
but by
anybody fixing a road or
any of the other government
uh sort of
jobs that are conducted i don't know
that you know documentation needs to be
provided for that
as it's just simply a
a clear scenario of what would happen
okay
are you all set representative smith
well um
yeah i don't think there's anything to
be gained by by following up i think
those statements were made um in very
strong language presented as facts and
out of respect for mr morrison i just
wanted to have the documentation of the
facts that he presented to us thank you
mr chairman
point made so
are there any other questions for mr
morrison
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you very much
uh the next person
is uh ross khan
thank you mr chairman can you hear me we
can
excellent uh
and thank you mr chairman and members of
the committee for holding this hearing
today
just for the record my name is ross
connolly i'm the deputy state director
for americans for prosperity in new
hampshire
and i'm here to voice our support for hb
currently there are very few avenues to
hold accountable government agencies who
have violated granite staters
constitutional rights
and as we've heard a big reason for this
is the doctrine of qualified immunity
this is a court-created doctrine that
gives immunity to government officials
from possible soup in a wide range of
issues
essentially making them immune to
accountability from these the citizenry
hb 111 would bring much needed
accountability to government agencies
this bill would not cause a flood of
lawsuits or many of the issues seen in
states like colorado because hb 111 does
not allow for legal action against an
employee only the employer in this case
a government agency
this change will incentivize government
entities to ensure their policies and
training
do not create the potential for a
violation of individual rights
i think we all should be able to agree
that bad actors no matter who they are
or who they work for
should be held to the same standard as
everybody else
and as we've seen this is a bipartisan
solution to bring accountability to all
government and not and and does not
single out a single uh government agency
or employees
a recent gallup poll conducted in
september 2020 showed only 20 percent 21
percent of the public having a very
strong trust in their state government
the public's trust in the core
institutions of society is waning and it
is even worse when asked about
individual agencies
and it is critical from our perspective
that that trust is restored
with these accountability measures hb
111 will help
improve granite staters confidence that
their government supports them and when
it doesn't they have proper recourse
this
legislation brings together groups from
all over the political spectrum who
recognize the need for citizen rights to
be upheld and defended and for these
reasons we urge the committee to move hb
111 ought to pass and i'd be happy to
take any questions if there are any
are there any questions for mr connolly
yes representative mclean
thank you mr chair um
mr conley you you mentioned colorado has
similar legislation passed there
uh yes uh uh i i mentioned colorado
since uh they got a lot of attention for
for passing a qualified immunity bill
that their legislation uh puts the
burden of proof on the employee is my
understanding not the employer
uh which from our perspective
uh incentivized
has the wrong incentives when you put
the burden on the employee then it could
result in and what the the previous
speaker was saying of officers
potentially changing their behavior uh
when conducting arrests if the burden of
proof is or the burden is put on the
agency and the employer then uh the the
incentive is to change
the agency's policies and the agency's
training
uh instead of uh the individual actions
of the the employee
good follow-up mr chair certainly
so in the case of colorado where they
really actually
it's different where they went after the
employee did they see any impact there
with respect to recruitment or anything
in that situation um because that would
be i think even a more severe case than
we would be looking at here in new
hampshire
i i do not uh have that information
unfortunately uh i i will defer to later
speakers who may be attorneys i am not
an attorney um but i uh if that question
is not answered i'll certainly follow up
with the committee and and provide that
information
thank you
thank you any other questions for mr
connolly
cnn thank you for your testimony today
thank you for your time next person is
john williams
mr chair and members of the
um the house judiciary committee uh with
your permission uh president gordon i'd
like to bring in on our testimony
a our third year law clerk her name is
audrey maliner mulliner
she certainly can join that's fine
well good morning um
for the record my name is john williams
i am the legislative director for the
department of health and human services
and with me
hi good morning am i coming through all
right
you appear as a cat but yeah
[Laughter]
perfect um so good morning mr chairman
and members of the committee
so for the record my name is audrey
mullener and i am one of the legal
interns for the department of health and
human services serving under director
williams
the department of health and services
appreciates the opportunity to comment
on the proposed legislation
uh and today we are limiting our
testimony to a request for a fiscal
analysis on this legislation
and as many many of you may be aware
under rsa
14 colon 44 roman i which falls under
the legislative budget assistance
statute it provides that all bills and
resolutions having an effect on revenues
expenditures
or fiscal liability of the state or city
or town or county which have a total
fiscal impact of 10 000
or more in each fiscal year over the
period covered by a fiscal note
shall be accompanied by a fiscal note
which sets forth the estimated fiscal
impact thereof
and to build on top of that um hb 111
does create a new cause of action under
state law touching on all branches of
state government and its political
subdivisions uh including county and
local government um as well as a waiver
of sovereign immunity in certain
circumstances
and if enacted um house bill 111 is
projected to result in increased
litigation with anticipated costs uh
exceeding the ten thousand dollar or
more threshold under rsa-14 calling 44.
and as introduced hb 111 does not have a
fiscal impact note to provide this
honorable committee and the legislature
with the necessary information
on the budgetary impact related to
revenues or expenditure
expenditures to the state uh or its
political subdivisions that were
previously mentioned
how however as most of you know on rsa
146 romans 5 does provide a remedy and a
mechanism to authorize the office of
legislative budget assistance to
complete a fiscal impact note at this
juncture
and to dovetail with that sub paragraph
a under this section provides that a
fiscal note may be requested after the
introduction of a bill
if a majority of a committee to which is
referred a bill not containing a fiscal
note votes to have one prepared by the
legislative budget assistant upon the
motion of a member of said committee
this completes our testimony on hb
and in the department of health and
human services happily remains available
as a resource
to the house judiciary committee as well
as the bill sponsor representative uh
paul burch
any other
any questions
for mr williams or ms milliner
yes
representative smith
thank you very much mr chair um uh thank
you very much mr williams and ms mullen
are for testifying are you aware that
this is the policy committee um
of
the legislative judiciary and not the
finance committee
so that the testimony that we
would most like to hear from your
distinguished department would be the
policy questions
raised
and do i assume that since you are
choosing to
only request that we ask for a fiscal
note that you have no problems at all
with the policy you're supportive of the
policy it's just that you're concerned
about the fact that there might be
financial implications that uh the
appropriate
uh committee should consider
and and mr chair responding to rep
smith's question as you'll see from the
rsa it doesn't set forth that it has to
be a financially related committee in
fact a policy committee and also the
full
house representatives have the authority
to request a fiscal note on legislation
and although i would absolutely agree
with you represent smith that this is a
policy committee and we fully understand
and appreciate that
for the committee to have the complete
picture we do feel it's important for
you to have a greater understanding
particularly in the year where there's a
pandemic we have a budget that's heading
before us to understanding what
implications there may be around this
relative policy initiative we do think
and we want to thank and appreciate our
conversations that we've had
with representative burch he's been very
open uh we have expressed some concerns
regarding some unanswered questions
around the legislation and perhaps other
state agencies or others may be weighing
in
on similar concerns regarding for
example the scope of the legislation as
it impacts all branches of
state government as well as the
political subdivisions thereof so there
are questions regarding how would this
relate for example to a state agency
like the national guard who as we know
are
working along with the department of
health and services around uh
immunization or the code 19. would this
expose those particular individuals to
a new cause of action within the state
and what would the fiscal implication be
around that so we do think it would be
helpful referee smith for you have this
information and i do reflect very fondly
uh on working with you when you were the
chair of house finance and also
considering the overlap of policy and
fiscal implications are very critical
and important
and i didn't know this moment or had
anything else to offer
i could just follow up um mr chair uh uh
i had i'm not commenting at all on the
request for a fiscal note that's a
perfectly legitimate uh request for you
to make what i am asking is that since
you are peering before the judiciary
committee where our primary focus
is the policy um i still have not heard
anything substantive from the department
of health and human services about the
policy
and there are
i know you've heard me say that when
they say it's not the money it's always
the money i understand that but the
money is based on a policy and i want to
know
what your position is on the policy
whether or not this committee chooses to
ask the lba for a fiscal note
representative gordon in responding to
representatives question the department
clearly in registering for our testimony
is not taking position on the bill but
we do remain a resource to the committee
on the underlying legislation either as
it might relate to the fiscal
implications of the bill because
certainly other um entities other
departments actually would be likely
taking lead on that physical analysis
like the department of admin services uh
perhaps the other other major uh
executive branch um
agencies but i do think in responding to
your question respectfully represented
smith i did outline that there are
several unanswered questions that i
think do relate to this bill that need
further exploration and so with that we
remain a resource to this committee to
represent birch uh and to others uh as
this bill makes its way through the
process but we do think it's critical
and we thought it was important enough
to come here today to at least bring to
your attention the request for a fiscal
analysis to be conducted on legislation
thank you representative simpson did you
have a question
yes i do thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
um
i'm glad that you presented yourself as
a resource because i actually do have a
question that i think you might be able
to help with and since i've not been
privy to your conversations with
representative birch i'd like to um ask
it
earlier in the hearing we heard that um
about who sort of makes split-second
decision-making in their in their
careers and in their jobs and
i was thinking about um
doctors and surgeons who are often
making split split-second decisions as
they work and um
and are liable for those decisions and
in fact have a lot of insurance um in in
order to cope with that liability
and so i wondered if there if you see
any kind of difference
in your
policy how you look at the policy from
the perspective of dhhs
then maybe um
the police association would look i
don't know if insurance is different in
the police um i would think it is in
some way different in the police
than it is in say doctors or nurses
um but maybe if you could talk about
that at all that would be helpful for me
and uh uh mr chair and responding to
representative simpson's question
uh you know we do come here today with
the lens of the department of health and
services and i do understand that from
the bills prime sponsored that the at
least initial uh intent is to look at
law enforcement and perhaps other
related areas such as corrections uh so
within our agency we certainly interact
with a lot of people you're probably
aware at new hampshire hospital that we
have patients there so from the co from
the context of a clinical perspective
there are some similarities between uh
us and the private sector uh on on many
occasions and so uh and i'd have to
defer to others and again that's the
request for the fiscal analysis being
done that it's my understanding and i
think there are others you could
leverage who would be a better resource
than our agency around the issues of the
state being self-insured at some point
if there are fiscal implications through
additional litigation being filed
that's the issue that i think is
important for at least a part of
critical information to come before this
committee and assessing whether or not
the policy linked up with the fiscal
implications makes sense and whether or
not you want to re-examine the scope of
the overall legislation if it is related
to law enforcement for example versus
those activities done by the department
of health and services in terms of
administering services to the public
that that would be helpful as part of
the conversation as well
representative alexander you had your
quest you had your hand up at one point
in time are you all set
i'm all set mr chair thank you
representative horrigan
thank you very much mr chair uh mr
williams um
i know uh dhhs uh because it's the
largest agency in the state and also
because of the range of issues it deals
it gets enough there's lots of citizens
that are
maybe unhappy the things you do do you
have a large
number disputes where
individuals
or
corporations want to sue
hhs but are now prevented to do so
because of the qualified immunity clause
i know that's kind of hard hard to know
but you you need give ideas that like a
large number of cases or just a small
number of cases
thanks
and mr chairman responding to
representative horgan's uh you know
question i first want to reflect that a
large sizable portion of our population
are very happy with the services that we
are providing to them to protect our
citizens and to provide the necessary um
resources to make them independent and
to really focus on their well-being so i
would take a little bit of a different
event on
that part of your ear question uh the
second part of it is i can certainly uh
working along with our legal counsel as
well as the department of justice kind
of generate uh an idea of what we have
in terms of litigation you probably may
have been aware uh within the last week
that um the division three at house
finance through the leadership of the
current chair of division 3
representative jess edwards actually had
the department of justice present on
litigation issues they certainly could
not talk about current or pending
litigation issues for obvious reasons
but they're able to come in with
examples from the past from various
state agencies uh in addition to the
department of open services believe it
or not there are litigation involving
many other state agencies out there as
well and and perhaps that kind of
information would be helpful to this
committee but i'm not prepared today to
walk you through that
thank you
if i could just follow up on that though
i'm just thinking in terms of my past
experiences and you have
cpsw's social workers
who are out there having to make
decisions with regard to moving
removing
children from homes
separating them from their parents at
times republicans
aren't you concerned with regard to this
legislation that it would have
a cost or you would bear the department
for the state and bear a cost as with
regard to defending those suits
and reps and boarder we we do and that's
why we respectfully came before the
committee uh making the request at your
election to uh utilize the existing
authority that you have to
directing the legislative budget
assistance office to provide you that
kind of information around the bill
any other questions for
williams or ms
melinda
mulliner
thank you for your testimony today
and thank you both very much
i thank you all very much thank you
and cordell johnston
thank you mr chairman cordell johnson
representing the new hampshire municipal
association in
a very strong opposition to this bill i
will follow this with
uh written testimony because there are
some pretty complicated issues here
but
the discussion so far has been about
so-called qualified immunity but this
bill does not just eliminate qualified
immunity it appears to eliminate every
kind of immunity that is available to
the state and political subdivisions
um
and there are there are several
different kinds of immunity i'm not
going to not going to talk about them
here i will in my letter but the idea of
municipal immunity
is that
the decisions
uh the discretionary decisions that all
kinds of
officials and employees have to make
every day
if if all of those decisions are subject
to lawsuit if something goes wrong
eventually local government becomes
impossible um and as um
lieutenant morrison said this is not
just it's not just police officers
it's uh road agents it's building
inspectors it's all kinds of
municipal municipal employees
if a if a building's building inspector
issues a certificate of occupancy
and does so in a reasonable manner
currently that
there is immunity for
injuries uh resulting from that if the
road agent
makes a decision about whether and how a
road should be repaired there is some
level of immunity for that
all of that immunity would be wiped away
uh by this legislation
um i want to correct something that uh i
think it was the representative from
americans for prosperity said he said
that this bill does not allow a suit
against the individual employee
um it very clearly does it expressly
says that the
the
agent the employee will be named in the
lawsuit
so um
qualified immunity and its
cousin official immunity
provide immunity only when the actor the
employee
is acting in good faith and reasonably
believes that his or her conduct is
lawful
under this bill the fact that the
employee believed that his or her
conduct was lawful
would be irrelevant that that could not
be asserted as an immunity or as a
defense
and so just to use
an example and this is very close to an
actual case that occurred a few years
ago
a police officer arrests someone for
violating a statute
the officer does everything exactly
right
and the person the person clearly
violated the law
he gets arrested but the supreme court
subsequently declares that statute
unconstitutional because the statute
violates the
person's first amendment or second or
fourth amendment rights or whatever
so now the person who was arrested
under this bill can sue the officer for
violating his constitutional rights
even though the officer had no reason
whatsoever to think that uh
that he was doing anything unlawful
under this bill
that lawsuit is likely to be successful
um
the person bringing the lawsuit gets
damages
whatever those may be
and the town has to pay his uh attorney
fees
and his litigation costs
and then
to top it all off under
what would be the new section 7
starting on line 21 on page 2
the police officer can get fired
which seems to be
an unconstitutional impairment of the
obligation of contracts
so
this bill creates a lot of problems
i think people need to keep in mind that
towns have no legal obligation to
provide police protection
they have no legal obligation to
keep their roads open or pick up trash
or provide recreational programs or many
any of the other most of the other
services that they provide
um
and when they start
being subject to
lawsuits for
the decisions that they make in good
faith in providing all of those services
they're going to start thinking about
whether they want to continue to provide
those services
so um
if you could wrap up yep i have i have
wrapped up
okay
are there any questions for mr johnston
yes representative alexander um thank
you mr chair and thank you mr johnson
for answering my question um i might be
confused in reading this um which
is common in some things um on line 22
on page one it's our
line 20 to 22 on page one it says an
individual may seek legal equitable
other relief on this chapter in the
state court for an injury caused by an
agent in the state of new hampshire but
it says in violation of a right under
laws for the constitution so you're
saying that
um if a if an individual like on the
municipal level violated um a law that's
in statute they would also qualify
and it's constitutional and its
constitutional right so it could be a
law or policy um and a constitutional
violation that would be subject to
um litigation
yes yeah by its terms this is this is
not limited to constitutional violations
okay follow up mr chair yes you may um
if this was narrowed down like would
that
alleviate a lot of your concerns
just to constitutional violations
that would alleviate a small subset of
my concerns
okay thank you
there'd still be a lot of concern in
there
there are other questions for mr johnson
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
thank you
the last person who pre-registered to
testify today is a patrick
jay cuomo from arlington virginia
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for the opportunity to speak
in support of hb 111 can everybody hear
me we can
great
my name is patrick jacomo i'm an
attorney at the non-profit institute for
justice which is a law firm that offers
all of our services to our clients pro
bono
my colleagues and i at the institute for
justice
support hb 111 for two important reasons
first hb 111 restores the concept of
constitutional accountability and
ensures unlike under the current regime
that where there is a constitutional
right that right is actually enforceable
and second hb 111
does so in a way that will not open the
floodgates of litigation it's very
reasonable and it ensures that the
appropriate accountability falls on the
appropriate people and damages fall on
the employers and not the individual
employees
first i'd like to get into this issue of
accountability a little bit further
under the us and new hampshire
constitutions their entire purpose is to
limit the government and the things that
its agents can do
and in large part that includes
infringing on individual rights
under doctrines created by the supreme
court like qualified immunity government
workers are allowed effectively allowed
to violate the constitution without any
recourse for the person whose rights
have been violated
now representative burch and mr bisonnet
have done a great job explaining
qualified immunities so i won't give the
big picture here but i think it would be
helpful to frame my explanation of how
qualified immunity works in response to
some things that were said by lieutenant
morrison and mr johnson
first i'll point out that qualified
immunity is
is in effect by default so unless a
plaintiff can show clearly established
law
the government worker by default is
immune from any constitutional or legal
claims in civil court and here this is
absolutely crucial when lieutenant
lieutenant morrison and mr johnson say
that qualified immunity only applies to
actions taken in good faith or not
reckless or not wanton actions that is
absolutely incorrect since 1982 when the
united states supreme court decided a
case called harlow versus fitzgerald
the standard for applying qualified
immunity does not take into
consideration good faith or
reasonableness all it asks is whether
there was an earlier court case that
said exactly what happened was
unconstitutional and to give you two
examples where recklessness and
wantonness were recently allowed there's
a case from the ninth circuit called
jessa versus city of fresno where police
officers were alleged to have stolen two
hundred thousand dollars and the ninth
circuit actually held although every
society throughout history knows
stealing is wrong because there's not an
earlier court case saying it's
unconstitutional these officers are
entitled to qualified immunity now on
the issue of recklessness there was
recently an 11th circuit case called
corbett versus vickers and in that case
a police officer while trying to shoot a
non-threatening family dog
shot a 10 year old instead and the 11th
circuit said that officer gets qualified
immunity it doesn't matter if their
actions were reckless so the concept of
good faith immunity does not exist in
american law and hasn't since 1982.
another thing that frequently comes up
in this context is that police officers
in particular have to confront
split-second decisions that they need to
make without fear of any sort of
liability now we don't disagree with
that we simply point out that qualified
immunity is not the mechanism to ensure
that police
aren't held account aren't held to
account for reasonable mistakes only
unreasonable mistakes
now earlier lieutenant morrison said
anytime the police search or sees
anything that's unconstitutional on that
point mr morrison is just simply wrong
on how the constitution operates the
constitution only limits unreasonable
searches and seizures and that standard
takes into account split-second
decisions that need to be made in all of
the circumstances that surround those
so reasonableness mr jack
jacomo if you could wrap up that would
be great sure just in some this this
bill will add accountability without uh
without flooding courts with lawsuits
and i'm happy to answer any questions
that the committee might have
yeah either yes representative maclean
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question all right so i'm just trying
to understand this since the harlow
versus fitzgerald case
um you have to show a violation of
clearly established case law
to overcome qualified immunity so
if there is no established case law and
you go into new situations
do you have an opportunity to establish
new case law i'm just having a real
struggle
with with
is there an opportunity since 1982 to
even establish new case law
am i answering the question correctly
so you're correct about the standard
which is that all that matters is
whether there's an earlier case the only
wrinkle today
is that courts effectively have
discretion to decide a new
constitutional issue but far more often
what they do is exercise discretion not
to decide it and instead simply say this
case gets thrown out because there's not
an earlier case and so for example in
both the 9th circuit and 11th circuit
cases i mentioned earlier the court
declined to establish those were
constitutional violations which means in
the future police in california and
washington state can steal knowing
they're protected by qualified immunity
and similar actions can be taken in the
11th circuit
so they have an opportunity to establish
a new precedent but they usually choose
not to they rarely choose exercises is
what you're saying that's correct
and
yes representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
jacomo for taking my question a previous
uh speaker talked about
the possible violation of a
constitutional right to contract if
an employee was fired under this
is that uh something you would agree
with
uh rep representative sylvia i'm not
exactly sure how that would apply in
these contexts other than through things
related to union collective bargaining
but uh that could easily be solved
simply by bargaining around that in the
future to ensure that termination is a
possibility if there's a violation of hp
thank you
are you all set representative sylvia
what's up
and are there any other questions
for mr jacomo
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
there is one hand up among the attendees
and that's uh
that's lynn marie cusack
yes thank you mr chair my name is lynn
marie kruzak the last name is spelled
c-u-s-a-c-k
and i am the director of professional
standards at the new hampshire
department of corrections
um we did not
pre-register for this bill but i felt
compelled in listening to the testimony
today
to um speak out because i believe that
the language of the bill as originally
written is broader than what has been
suggested by today's testimony we've
heard much discussion about qualified
immunity today and qualified immunity is
different than sovereign immunity
sovereign immunity is something that the
legislature has already waived in 541 b
and that statute
does have exceptions for
when a case
can
where sovereign immunity is accepted out
and and the legislature hasn't waived it
saying that the state may still use that
as a jurisdictional reason
not to go forward with the case
which is different than qualified
immunity qualified immunity is a defense
in a case
and while i said that i am the director
of professional standards at the
department of corrections i have also
spent approximately 15 years at the
department of justice in new hampshire
the attorney general's office litigating
all sorts of cases from the cases
relative to
our transportation department and
slippery roads to our cases with
dhhs and individuals being
brought under scrutiny for the way that
they handle cases with child protection
or
my recent cases before leaving the
attorney general's office for the
department of corrections in litigation
matters whether they are with
corrections officers
or
state police also
so i have a breadth of experience in how
new hampshire operates with sovereign
immunity and with
qualified immunity so
rsa
again 541b
19 would essentially be
nullified done away with by the language
of this statute
also
one of the things that attorney
bissonnette indicated is that their what
the statute was doing or what hb 111
does is allow for responding at superior
to exist
that already exists in the state of new
hampshire under 541b9a
which
allows
the
court to make a determination
that the state will be responsible for
the actions of its agent employee or
official
when those actions
are
also when they're brought against the
state excuse me that individual the
state will step in and defend and
indemnify that individual
under another statute in the state which
is rsa 99d
so all of these statutes already exist
in new hampshire
but the language as written
in house bill 111 is much broader than
just
dealing with qualified immunity i would
suggest that if um you could just wrap
up your testimony that would be
appreciated certainly my my my last
suggestion was going to be that the
committee do um to look at this in a
study committee and um maybe there's
language that can be adopted by all of
the individuals that are stakeholders so
that some language can be presented back
to the
the committee
thank you for your testimony are there
questions at all for miss cusack
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony today
thank you for the opportunity
you're very welcome i don't see any
other hands up among the attendees
that being the case i will
declare the hearing closed on house bill
and the committee will be in
reset uh
representative smith do you have a
question um
thank you mr chair i have an apology
having been in solitary confinement for
almost a year i find that i talk to
myself a lot and apparently i had
neglected to mute myself at one point
and was therefore
heard talking to myself and i want to
apologize for that i'll try my best not
to keep on behaving that way
well it was a very interesting
conversation so
um we'll see we'll see you all
the committee will be in recess we'll
gather again at one o'clock thank you
thank you
[Music]
make myself beautiful if that's possible
if i actually stopped me on the street
but come in somebody
uh
wow
okay
okay trash
are we starting up on 212.
and the emails from coming in all
through the
okay
ned do you anticipate that you will be
doing any executing on friday
no
the
my plan is to hear our bills on friday
and then what i'd like to do is on
tuesday when we meet make that full day
and exec session
at that point in time we'll have 31
bills
and to exec
and
and so i figured that we would make a
day of after
after that
um
well i've i know i've been given that
following friday again uh for a full day
we have seven bills to here
and i'm told we might get an eighth bill
after this house session there's
apparently another
uh pfass bill that
is sort of complementary to the bills we
have and they're talking about sending
that to us as well
and
uh so we may have eight bills but we'll
have seven bills at that point in time
so
long and short as
i uh hope to exec on tuesday next
tuesday as much as the second
yes as much as we possibly can get done
and okay
and then
well here we'll have that friday excuse
me
we'll hear the uh
remaining bills
and then i'm hoping that we will have
one another full day of executing uh to
get our bills done before the 11th
and i've asked
asked to have
unfortunately we've been meeting on
tuesdays tuesday the 9th happens to be
town meeting day
and we don't ordinarily hold hearings on
not to mention the fact on the town
moderator but
um
so
long and the short is i've asked that if
we have a day a full day at the
beginning of that week either the 8th or
the 10th
if that's possible
to finish our work
that ok make sense to you
sure does
pretty much everything you say makes
sense to me
not 100
but
pretty close
channel
nice well it'd be one o'clock i'll call
the house judiciary committee back to
order
and our first item in business this
afternoon is a hearing on house bill
212 relative to drug courts and
alternative drug offender grant programs
the primary sponsor of that bill was
representative james colleen
and if he's available
we'll call upon him to testify
i see him
members of the committee may can you
hear me we can
thank you so much for um hearing me
today i come before you to present
hb 212
this was a bill um
that was crafted out of concern of a
constituent of mine
whose
son-in-law has gone through the drug
court program and had a difficult time
with it
i will tell you that i did
speak with the honorable
nato
about her drug court program with this
we had a long discussion before i
decided to go ahead with filing it
and
there was not a lot of opposition
the purpose of this bill
is to address one of the situations
that
my constituent found when
her son-in-law was trying to find his
feet again
after going through the drug court
program
and it is an enabling bill it allows the
judge at their discretion
to order that a social worker also visit
the person who's in the drug court
program in addition to the parole
officer
because currently
although that's something they like to
do from time to time it's not
it's not something that gets ordered
along with with everything else
and
my constituent
related to me that
her son-in-law did not have a lot of
skills and he had grew up
selling drugs
and
was finding it very difficult and
emotionally troubling and and had a lot
of serious
emotional problems while trying to get
back into society after completing the
drug drug court program
and
the parole officer who would visit was
primarily concerned with was he doing
drugs was he
dealing drugs was he breaking the law or
any of the guidelines of his parole
and not really looking into whether that
person
was
emotionally okay
finding their feet
able to
have the strength to search for work and
find other
other alternatives
this bill does play into the next bill
i'll present be presenting at 1 30 uh
for you but i wanted to keep them
separate in case the committee had an
opinion different on one bill than the
other
and and so that is where this bill comes
out of it allows the judge to order that
a social worker
be at one time or
multiple times visit and check up on the
social well-being of the person who has
exited the drug court program or is in
the process of parole through the drug
court program
to try to prevent the recidivism that we
see
happen
too often
and with that i'll take any questions
thank you rather any questions for
representative
xenon thank you for your testimony today
oh sorry representative rice you have a
question
just one question you said that this was
enabling legislation but that they they
have the ability to do it now but they
don't do it
that much
why would this legislation make them
do this more it would appear on the
checklist of things the judge can go
through when when issuing the parole and
and be an item that comes and pops to
mind more often in my opinion
and i think that uh judge nato if she's
going to be um
speaking on this which i think she she
told me she would be testifying um so i
assume she's she's on deck to do so and
i
i apologize for not knowing because i
can't see the list of attendees
uh normally i'm a
technologist and i can see all that for
the committee but i don't hear as just a
participant
judge nadeau will be testifying next
okay great thank you
representative morgan
thank you mr chair maybe i'll wait and
see what uh justice nato has to say
first before i asked that's my question
i guess so thank you
thank you
and are there any other
questions
seeing none uh thank you for your
testimony today
thank you members of the committee i
appreciate your time
and we will call upon judge nadeau to
provide her testimony today
i understand that she has a hearing
today and will be able to stay with us
but she may have some comments on the
next bill that we're going to hear this
afternoon as well
before she leaves
hi there can you all hear me
we can
great thank you mr chairman and thank
you members of the committee it's really
an honor to be before you i wish we
could be in person i'm sure you hear
that all the time
i did have a very good conversation with
the sponsor of this bill we talked at
length about drug court and how drug
court works and while i don't have a
strong opposition to this bill i don't
think it's necessary and i do think it
could cause some confusion
among the drug court programs already in
place it is obviously a well-intended
bill and i'm always impressed when
legislators have the ability to listen
to their constituents and act promptly
so let me just give you a quick
thumbnail of why i think it would not be
necessary first of all
we have 10 operating felony adult drug
courts in the state
and all of them provide for
mental health counseling
case management services probation
services and each individual
participant in drug court is assessed
for their individual needs
and they are required to comply with an
individualized treatment plan often that
includes group counseling that includes
substance use counseling mental health
health counseling three hours a day
three days a week it includes individual
counseling it includes random drug
testing it includes case management
services
self-help groups and more and the
program lasts between 18 and 24 months
for some people it lasts longer
and for those who graduate they still
remain on probation for a year
if they're coming out of the prison
they'll remain on probate parole for a
year so we can do some follow-up
so i i do i think sometimes that parents
and parents in law of people who are in
drug court maybe get one side of the
story
from the person who attended drug court
you also have to keep in mind that the
people that we're serving what we
categorize and the target population is
high risk high need that means there are
people that would otherwise be headed to
state prison if we didn't do something
about the substance use disorder they
are not dangerous but they're high risk
for reoffending over and over again and
their high need because they have a deep
deep substance use disorder that started
when they were young
so we do provide mental health services
social work services case management
services and they are required in each
program
some people engage better than others in
the programming that we provide
and my concern about this particular
bill it indicates that if
these services are ordered even though
they're already provided
they sh they the program shall be
eligible for funding we are you already
do fund drug courts which includes the
mental health component and i've already
gotten some calls from counties that
think this means they're going to get
extra funding and they're not just yet
because we haven't asked for an increase
since 2016 when you all passed statewide
drug court so i believe it is well
intended i believe it is unnecessary i
do think it will cause some confusion
and depending sometimes you have good
probation officers sometimes you have
ones that aren't as proactive but they
do they are able to link up with those
services even after they graduate from
drug court and i i so appreciate the
opportunity to talk right now and and
with you recognizing that i have to get
back on the bench for this second bill
and i do have someone that will testify
already so that it's part of the record
but i have the same concerns regarding
the second bill
vocational and educational components
are required for people who don't have a
job they are required to get a ged
or engage in training if it's
appropriate to their recovery usually
that happens near the end of drug court
so we do have those services in place as
well again somebody may or may not be as
amenable to receiving them
and the concern in the second bill is it
talks about pre-adjudication we don't
have any pre-adjudication drug court
people have to plead guilty get a
suspended sentence be on probation
acknowledge their guilt be accountable
before they're in drug court so that is
my real thumbnail sketch of what we do
i'm happy to answer questions and if
there's any interest in the future when
you're not swamped the way you're
swamped of a full drug court
presentation i'd be happy to provide
that some time down the line as well
thank you for your testimony
representative oregon did you have a
question yes sure um
my concern looking at it and i
maybe
i may be able to put my concern to rest
risk is it sounds like this is making uh
participating in
mental health counseling uh
at least to a certain extent
non-voluntary since you have to do it as
part of your
uh
basic your drug court program which is
basically a form of uh probation so um
is that
my concern uh well placed and um and
then there already and i there are other
cases where people uh
are ordered to go i guess it must be
ordered to go through you know mental
health counseling or social work
counseling well that that does happen
that is a very good question drug court
is voluntary someone only enters drug
court if they agree to enter drug court
once they've agreed to enter drug court
they have to comply with the program
requirements and some of them take them
a while to get used to because they
don't like having their time so
scheduled but the program is voluntary
they are required to follow the
components of drug court and drug courts
actually operate under very specific
national standards we have books of
standards that have been you know the
elements of drug court have been studied
empirically so that's why i think it's
also important to stick with the
national standards
when someone is just on regular
probation without drug court a probation
officer may recommend that they get
mental health counseling and if they
don't follow through it could constitute
a violation of probation but that's a
great question great thank you
representative lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you judge
nato for taking my question and this is
a short one um you said that services
are available while folks are in the
drug um
court program
so as far as the services
are those and you said they're already
funded are those services um chargeable
to the
person's medical insurance
that's a good question if someone has
insurance they
their treatment can be covered by
insurance
90 percent 95 percent of the people we
see in drug court do not have insurance
some of them are medicaid eligible
because now we are a medicaid expansion
state so that's why we don't have to
fully fund the drug courts they're able
to get reimbursement for their services
through medicaid
thank you very much
any other questions
it's not thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr chairman and again thank
you for taking me so quickly good luck
no problem good luck on the bench thank
you
okay and
our
next witness
speaker
sure
uh would be um
emily benton
actually not didn't ask to testify
actually i don't have anybody else who
pre-registered to testify today
is there anybody else
who does wish to testify today
if if you do please raise your hand
i
see no hands
so i'll close the hearing on house bill
and we have about
15 minutes or 20 minutes before our next
hearing
i know
just for everyone that with regard to
sign ups there were 16 people who did
register their support for 212 and 14
people who
registered in opposition
just note that if you're listening in
our next hearing will be on house bill
569 and we will call that promptly at 1
and we'll be in recess until then
two
shhh
so
foreign
okay
it's too much
well first of all need to fight the
history association of that sense of
commission yeah
oh and they they're on board they're
yeah electively
that's what they are representative
representative
wahlberg you are not muted in there
pretty much
all right
she
foreign
stop
me
what
oh
all right
so what are they gonna be like for
tomorrow reception
we are
gorgeous out there now
okay
so
french
shhh
are yes
see
we did
wow
before we get started i just wanted to
let you know that
we
were set for
next tuesday the second we're going to
be
uh when we're going to make that an
all-day exec session
and then
on friday we'll hear the last bills that
we have right now we have seven
there may possibly be an eighth bill if
we get another one after our session
next week
and then
it looks like we will have the tenth to
finish executing our bills
and that will be a full day
if we need it to do the exact
chair may i ask a question
yes you may
i missed the date you said between march
2nd and 10th i think you might have
mentioned another date the 5th friday
the 5th
great thank you
for hearings yeah
okay it's 1 30
and our
next bill to be heard is house bill 569
and this bill is also
primarily sponsored by representative
spelaine and i would call upon
representative spelaine to provide his
testimony today
thank you members can you hear me
thank you members of the committee uh
honorable all of you uh for for having
me here today to present hb 569
i present this bill again as a request
from a constituent who was deeply
concerned in making sure that our drug
courts
effectively
address people
based on the personal experience that
she and her family has had
um
this
part of uh this bill in particular
addresses
the requirements that uh
the court and again it's an enabling
bill it allows the judge to order that
that a particular participant
as part of their graduation from drug
court must participate in
vocational
educational programs
to give them a different career to fall
back on
the problem that my constituent had was
that her son-in-law had only ever
had a career of selling drugs from the
time he was a very young man
and
they were very afraid as a family uh
afraid for
her daughter and his children and the
ability to sustain themselves as a
family if if he was not able to
transition into something other than
drug selling and they wanted to be able
to give him an opportunity
to have some other
course of action other than falling back
on what he considered easy money
and
i understand that some of this is
already done as as judge nadeau has uh
explained
this however puts it on the radar
for the court
so that they they can actually order
that that somebody who has no skills and
has no alternative to go to
should complete these programs not just
participate in them but actually
complete them successfully
before they can be graduated from drug
court and their probation that follows
drug court
and i i will point out here i i think
there might have been some confusion
because judge nato talked on two bills
when before she left
she talked about the pre-adjudication
aspect
there's no pre-adjudication in hb 212 we
heard earlier
there's no mention of that at all it's
only here in this one
and this is because they put in
pre-adjudication post-adjudication or a
combination program
and the reason they did it that way was
so that
prior to the the complainant
agreeing to the drug court and pleading
guilty they could present the fact that
this would be
uh a requirement was that vocational
training was going to be required and so
they could have all the information when
they decide to volunteer for drug court
that part of that was going to be dr job
skills training and that they needed to
know ahead of time before they did their
guilty plea and entered the drug court
program that that they'd be required to
find a profession and and do something
um now as you know vocational training
can take a lot of aspects they could
choose anything they want to but
um
i'm going outside of my standard
conservative republican bounds by
presenting this bill because i
understand that
this is
allocating funds
for a new program
and i may be
opposed by a lot of republicans but i
feel that
any investment and i think i'm backed up
by facts any investment that we do to
try to prevent
that
person who dealt in drugs from going
back to drug dealing is a savings in the
long run on the community and on that
that person and the cost of the state
and i believe that the investment that
we might take under putting someone
through vocational education programs as
part of their drug court as a state
is going to pay back
this state and the members of this state
in the long run
by
offering
an opportunity to flourish under
normal
job opportunities and prevent somebody
from going back to drug dealing
and that's
essentially what i have to say here
i'll take any questions if anyone has
them
are any questions for representative
spelaine
representative mclean
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question just to follow up on
on the free adjudication um aspect of
this which i think was one of the
concerns of of judge nato specifically
with this bill
if it it's a part of the
pre-adjudication you kind of think
you're going down one path
but then you go through and you actually
plead guilty
um does that tie
down
what um
the
the judge is able to do um and take away
latitude because it's been
pre-adjudicated how would that work in
practice
um
i wish she was here to answer that
because as a judge she's got
far more experience than i do on how
that actually works out in practice my
understanding
is that
it gives the judge the ability
pre-adjudication to say
as part of your
your
going through probation and and the
programs you will be required to take
through the drug court you will be
required to take vocational training you
know you may choose which area of
vocational training you go into but you
will be required to take it and complete
it
which may mean
that
in some instances their probation is
extended to the end of the time that
they finish their program
because they need to complete their
program
but i think that
it's
it's a good thing in the long run and i
don't believe this has any impact if
they choose not to go into the drug
court because this is tied directly to
entering the drug court so if they are
told prior to adjudication that this is
going to be a contingency and it's
and it's part of entering the drug court
program
it would still remain in effect when
they enter the program
but if they decided to
wave off the program and just go to jail
and through the regular process and not
go through the drug court program
obviously any
any requirement that they
entered into based on pre-adjudication
for the drug court program is not
applicable because they're no longer in
the drug court program
thank you
representative morgan
thank you thank you very much mr chair
this is representative oregon from
durham um
my question is uh well i guess guess
both these bills
pay for uh
pay for the things they're paying
through through the uh drug uh
the drug up
the drug offender grant program so he
tells a little bit more about what that
is and where the money comes from and
looks like he gives matching
grants to the counties but where does he
other half of it come from thanks
thank you honorable horrigan i
appreciate the question
we do have funds from the federal
government that are tied into our drug
court programs
and we also have funds that we have
allocated in our general fund to fund
those programs and i believe so far we
have seen it to be a great success
in providing
benefit to the communities and to the
offenders who can
successfully complete the program
over the cost to the community and the
cost to the state for someone who is
just in and out of prison
thank you thank you
thank you mr uh thank you very much and
thank you uh
mr chair
are there any other questions for
representative spelaine
seeing none thank you for your testimony
again
and
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on the bill
yes
uh richard head
i think you have to unmute your head
there we go are we can you hear me now
we can
perfect sorry about that
um
thank you mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is richard head
i'm the government affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch my primary
ask is
as you heard in the testimony for house
bill 212
judge nato was unavailable for this
hearing
because she had to go on the bench for a
1 30 hearing
we asked that her testimony during the
testimony for house bill 212 be
incorporated into house bill 569.
i am by no means an expert in drug court
the way judge nato is
um if you do have additional questions
for her she is planning on being uh in
attendance for the two o'clock bill uh
house bill 578 um and i don't know if
mr chairman if he wanted to suspend so
that an additional question can go to
her
at the very beginning at two o'clock
when she gets on but
she will be coming back for that bill uh
when her hearing is over
the other
part of the bill
in both bills these as judge nato said
these are long involved programs that
can take years to complete
those are you know the needs are
assessed throughout the the time that an
individual is in that program
uh there are evolving needs that can
occur during the course of these these
programs uh as a participant goes
through them but they can be very
long-term uh and they're quite involved
and have a number of
of
uh specialties or or areas that services
are provided not just the ones that are
included in these bills
but as judge nato uh indicated in her
prior testimony vocational services are
currently part of the program
uh and for the reasons that she uh
discussed in her testimony we believe
that this bill would is not necessary
and with regard to the pre-adjudication
issue it does talk about drug court
and really that has not occurred
pre-adjudication so the drug court
is not actually operating
pre-adjudication relative to an
individual
so just the the
timing there would not make sense
i'd be happy to answer any questions but
as i said before i'm by no means the
drug court expert thank you very much
are there any questions for attorney
head
yes representative chase
thank you for taking my
question
as i read this so would this be like
having to have people go actually
through a vocational school or where we
need so many um apprenticeships
say plumbing heating that type of thing
could
the public offer
a position where they would
take someone under their wing and teach
them or would it have to be
a actual program do you know you know i
i don't know specifically i think
there's a great deal of flexibility in
terms of the vocational training that
can go on
i will note that the bill also says you
know the drug court may which is which
is really adopting what is currently
happening you know that is always an
option and it is in fact part of the
the program analysis that is that is
done for every individual the specifics
as to who actually is able you know
does the vocational training
um i think the there's a great deal of
flexibility there but i don't
i do not have the specifics i apologize
thank you very much
are there any other questions for
attorney ed
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today great thank you very much
and is there anyone else who wishes to
testify i see representative spelaine's
hand is up you are you looking to speak
again
yes sir if that would be appropriate i
wanted to make a comment on on the um
the the
using of the word may
um as i mentioned this was an enabling
bill and after my discussions with judge
nato she said that it would not
interfere in any way with what they
currently do if we said may it would
just formalize what they currently do so
that it was more of a documented
formalized
aspect of the process
rather than an informal
something that's done without any kind
of of
documentation
[Music]
any any other questions for
representatives fellaini while we have
them
thank you
and is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
seeing none
declare that the hearing on house bill
569 is closed
and again i
find ourselves
having a break i guess i didn't plan
very well today
our next hearing is house bill 5
and that's scheduled for 2 o'clock
and so
and but we do i will say we have lots of
speakers on that bill so
and so
i'll declare the
committee to be in recess until our
hearing at two o'clock
chief
so
this
next
so
right
[Music]
so
let's look
uh
yesterday
and
see
other shoes
okay it being the appointed hour i'll
call the
house judiciary committee back to order
and we our item of business next item of
business is to hear house bill 578
this is a relative to standards for
mental health courts
primary sponsor being representative
cannon
i would note that
on the
pre-registration on the sign ups
156 people signed up in support and zero
people signed up in opposition
and
president cannon being the primary
sponsor we'll call upon her to introduce
the bill
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
the record my name is representative
jerry cannon and i represent strafford
county district 18.
i've sent you a copy of a prepared
testimony essentially summarizes a
commission report
that we've done over the past two years
you should have received more details
about the commission that met
during that time
the commission didn't identify specific
details of what we believe the court
should do
instead we recognized
that the court is already moving in the
right direction
and that they own their own plans
new hampshire's courts have already
implemented
drug courts consistently around the
state
they based them on best practices that
were have been defined nationally
they haven't yet implemented mental
health courts consistently across the
state
due in part to the lack of best
practices
that have
need to be defined now still need to be
defined nationally
it's time that new hampshire
take responsibility for defining our own
best practices
modeled after
mental health courts
in our counties that have already proven
their ability to identify those people
who have committed crimes
influenced by their mental health
conditions
and provide paths to bring them into
back into the community at large as
productive citizens
so
to do this we need to task the courts
with developing their own plan for
rolling out state mental health courts
throughout the state adhering to the
best practices we have developed here
the court through the chief justices
office and the judicial branch of our
government needs to develop and own the
responsibility for a rollout plan
they are responsible for keeping the
legislative and executive branches aware
of the resources they need
to implement the plan
including manpower facilities use of
external health care resources
the cost and most importantly the cost
savings associated with their plan
these are the reasons for bringing this
bill forward
you will hear more about the reasons why
we need to test the chief justices
office to bring a plan forward during
this hearing
our our mental health courts and the
benefits
to the state are worth the effort
these courts benefit the state the
residents of new hampshire
our constituents
and the people who have been charged
with crimes they have committed
due in part
to their mental health conditions
i want to urge you to vote out to pass
on 578
and i know that we will have a number of
presenters after me
and even though i may take your
questions
i believe that there's other people
on the list who'll be better able to
address them
thank you
are you any questions for representative
cannon
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today thank you
and
to testify
as well we have
ebony sullivan
i think you have to unmute yourself
hi everyone can you hear me
we can
all right i'm ebony sullivan and i'm
here to testify today before you
i am in support of house bill 578 and
would like to share my experience with
the mental health as a former
participant in the community connections
program
this program is run by the mental health
center of greater manchester and works
directly with the mental health court
both district and superior
in order to give you a clear picture of
how mental health court has changed my
life i have to give you a little bit of
my background
i will not get into too much detail and
respect for everyone's time
i am open to answering any questions
after i conclude
i will start by saying that my childhood
included many forms of trauma
this trauma affected my my choices
throughout my life
as a teen i found a coping mechanism
which was drugs and alcohol
i continued to self-medicate for years
i also got into a very unhealthy
relationship and became a teen mother at
the age of 16.
i always thought that there was
something quote unquote wrong with me i
didn't react to life the way other
people did and i felt disconnected from
the world
the only thing i knew that helped was
drugs and alcohol
as years went by my unhealthy
relationship got worse physical and
mental abuse became a regular occurrence
eventually on january 23 2014 my husband
and i got into a physical altercation
as a result i was arrested and charged
with four felonies
at this time i felt like my life was
over and i had no hope
the day i had court my public defender
came to me and suggested i try community
connections program
i immediately thought i'm not crazy why
would i go to mental health
i had developed a stigma against mental
health and believed it was a shameful
thing to need help
the the court liaison at that time
explained the program in more detail to
me and ultimately i decided to try it
out what did i have to lose
i didn't realize at that time but my
life was about to change forever
at my intake appointment a weight was
lifted off my shoulders i was educated
about my diagnosis and i was told there
was treatment for me i finally felt like
i was going to be okay
i fully immersed myself into this
program
i got to work on myself and i continued
to make progress throughout the entire
year
when i graduated i went up front of the
court and i shared and with the new
participants who were getting ready to
start this program
i felt so empowered and so excited about
the journey i was about to start i
continued and
continued my treatment after graduation
and eventually got to a point where i
was comfortable on my own
to make a long story short on january
28th of this year i celebrated seven
years of sobriety and in august of this
year i will be cigarette free for seven
years too i got out of that unhealthy
relationship i have primary custody of
my two youngest children
my family relationships have improved
and i've developed self-love
i currently work at the mental health
center of greater manchester as a
certified peer specialist and certified
recovery support worker i work on the
assertive community treatment team
mcst which is the mobile community
support team
i actively participate in mental health
court as a peer mentor and i am very
passionate about this program because it
gave me something i had lost and that
was hope
i would like to give that gift to as
many people as i can and i believe
passing this bill will help do that
thank you for your time and i'd like to
dedicate this to my sister shauna marie
martin who died february 20th 2018 she
lived with schizophrenia for almost half
her life thank you so much
thank you for your testimony today
are there any questions for ms sullivan
see none thank you thank you again for
your testimony
and
the next person would be jake jake barry
he's available
yes good afternoon mr chair thank you so
much for having me uh my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
of new futures as many of you know we
are a nonpartisan nonprofit health
policy and advocacy organization
uh we've been working for more than 20
years to address behavioral health
issues in our state i do have my own
statement i served as clerk of our
mental health course committee that uh
looked into this matter last year a new
future stands strongly strongly and
supported this bill but
rather than reading my statement uh
senator john morgan who was the chair of
the committee uh was planning to join us
this afternoon he's not able to testify
so he did uh he did pass along his
statement to me and asked me to read it
so i'm happy to defer my own to read his
if that would be appropriate
it would be we we do have 10 people who
are signed up to speak so if you could
be
uh
be uh
i'll go as quickly as i'm aware of the
time i'd appreciate it of course sure as
i mentioned this is from uh former
senator morgan
the chair of our mental health course
committee
uh honorable chair i regret not being
with you to deliver this testimony in
person and i appreciate the opportunity
to share this statement with you i'm so
grateful for the incredible diligent
work of every member of the mental
health courts commission that i was
honored to chair last year uh and the
report we submitted together was one of
my proudest contributions while serving
in the state senate
currently mental health courts operate
in six of our ten counties yet
defendants with mental health issues and
belknap carroll co-os and sullivan
counties do not have the option or
opportunity to take part in the re
rehabilitative programs offered through
mental health court and instead must go
through the traditional criminal justice
system
the new hampshire department of
corrections estimates that between 30
and 46 percent of adults incarcerated in
state prisons have mental illness 75
percent have a history of substance
abuse and the women's state women's
prison incident rates are even higher
mental health courts have demonstrated
the capacity to improve outcomes when
set up and when set up and implemented
correctly additionally they save
valuable taxpayer funds from being spent
on needless and repetitive incarceration
these courts offer a different more
effective path toward rehabilitation for
those alleged offenders experiencing
mental health issues a path with
improved outcomes in terms of community
safety reduced substance use recidivism
and an overall improvement the quality
of life new hampshire has seen the
impact of these diversion programs in
the form of drug courts which have
graduated more than 400 individuals
since the statewide system was founded
in 2016. honorable committee members new
hampshire needs mental health courts as
an optional diversion program which will
deliver a demonstrable benefit to every
member of this state i urge you to pass
house bill 578
from senator morgan
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for mr barry
zing none thank you very much thank you
next person is susan stearns she's
available
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is susan stearns and i'm the deputy
director of nami new hampshire the
national alliance on mental illness
it is on behalf of nami new hampshire
that i am here to testify in support of
house bill 578.
in the interest of full disclosure i
will tell you that i do volunteer as a
board member for the mental health
center lakes region mental health center
in laconia where i have a loved one who
received services
i too had the privilege to serve as a
member of the commission to study
expanding mental health courts statewide
which was legislatively created with
passage of senate bill 51 in 2019
it is out of the commission's
recommendations of course that we have
this legislation before you today
it's important to look at mental health
courts in the context of the larger
mental health and criminal justice
system overall
a study done by bernard harcourt of the
university of chicago school of law in
2011 on the institutionalization of
people with mental illness
found that over the past 70 years
little has changed
while the number of people in hospital
settings has dramatically decreased the
number of people with mental illness
incarcerated in jails and prisons
has just as dramatically increased
while nami new hampshire firmly believes
that people who commit serious crime
should be prosecuted
we are opposed to the increasing
criminalization of individuals with
mental illness
the commission found that research
indicates when implemented right that
mental health courts reduce new arrests
endangerment incarcerated
increase treatment engagement reduce
corrections expenditures improve overall
health com health outcomes and most
significantly reduce human suffering
but we know there are not enough mental
health course nationally and certainly
not here in new hampshire as you've
heard we have we have mental health
courts in only six counties
those mental health courts have been
driven by several factors most notably
strong community partnerships that
include judges and investment of money
and resources by their counties
although the work of these mental health
courts is commendable
this peace mental approach has
inequities your access to a mental
health court depends upon where you
arrested and sometimes where you reside
nearly weekly at nami new hampshire we
receive calls to our information
resource line
from families who have a loved one
with a mental illness who has been
arrested and is being held in the county
jail
too often with no treatment and
frequently awaiting a bed at new
hampshire hospital
far too often we receive calls from
family members whose loved one was at a
local hospital
boarding in the emergency department
while waiting for a bed at new hampshire
hospital when they became agitated or
aggressive
leading to their arrest and what is
ultimately the diversion from emergency
department and medical treatment for the
county house of corrections
yesterday there were 56 adults and 22
children waiting for an inpatient
psychiatric bed here in new hampshire
five of those adults were waiting in
correctional facilities
it should be noted that the day prior on
sunday there were 59 adults waiting
five of whom were in correctional
facilities
it is a very sad reality that once an
individual has landed in a county
correctional facility their weight for
an inpatient bed and appropriate
psychiatric treatment will actually be
longer than if they were boarding in the
emergency department
when we receive calls to our information
resource line from folks who are in this
situation and have a loved one who has
been arrested
we hold our breath frankly after asking
where
that person was arrested hoping that it
will be in a jurisdiction where mental
health court is an option
it is frankly heartbreaking when we have
to tell a family that there is no mental
health court in that area that their
loved one will not even have the
opportunity to be evaluated as to their
appropriateness for an alternative
sentencing program
a program that could provide them with
treatment and supervision working to
build a full life in their community and
avoiding incarceration
the commission also found that
data and analysis amongst new
hampshire's mental health courts vary
significantly from one court to the
other
but there are is data out there that
demonstrates the impact of these
sentencing alternative sentencing
programs
the hillsborough county's community
connections mental health court has
demonstrated significant cost savings
with a total of over hundred and fifty
thousand dollars estimated to be saved
in 2018 alone
now the community connections project is
a robust one it was developed and is
still guided by the hillsborough county
coalition on mental health and justice i
have been privileged to serve as that
coalition's facilitator for the past 12
years
we have representatives across the array
of services including the from the
courts community mental health public
defenders prosecutors
hospitals et
cetera cut you short but if you could
sort of wrap up the testimony that would
be appreciated absolutely
in developing its report and
recommendations the commission
recognized early on the need to
implement statewide standards mental
health courts this will create more
parity amongst those already in
existence
and help lay the foundation for the
development of a full complement of
mental health courts statewide it's a
critical first step in creating equal
access for justice involved grant that
staters living with mental illness
we know that these courts keep time and
money
improved and will appropriate standards
improve outcomes
we know that the anguish that families
feel or if they're struggling right now
to help their loved ones navigate these
systems is real
for all these reasons on behalf of
families across the granite state i urge
you to vote ought to pass on house bill
578.
thank
thank you are there any questions for ms
terence
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony today
the next person would be shelley golden
good afternoon everyone
my name is shelly golden and i am the
grafton county mental health court
coordinator and i've been in this
position for about 12 years now in
grafton county we established three
mental health courts at the circuit
court level
and i am here uh in support of house
bill 578
my testimony was um actually submitted
in writing that include grafton county
mental health court statistics in full
and a list of our current 15 new new
hampshire mental health courts
i do want to point out that uh currently
our our new hampshire mental health
courts um many of us meet monthly
um over zoom right now and but we've
done that for um almost two years
and our efforts are trying to learn from
each other what's working well within
our programs and
how to make what we're doing more
effective
on all levels so
we're happy to be here today
to be able to share with you and
hopefully make this step forward towards
standards
and looking at those standards to pull
us together and fur further unify
us and our collaborative efforts that
we've already
we've already begun
to point out in grafton county um we
did recognize cost savings we did this
we did study 2019
we
realized savings of
seven hundred and twelve thousand
dollars um by keeping people in the
community and out of our county jail to
receive treatment and supervision
through mental health court
and we also realized a very low
recidivism rate of 14 percent
and also realized because we didn't have
participants in jail utilizing county
funds for psychotropic medications
uh we realized a saving of 62 000
in medication savings
there are a lot of programs mental
health courts and actually currently
seven states in the united states that
have worked on developing standards for
mental health courts in their states so
we've got people to learn from we've got
people right here dedicated and ready
with um statistics with the mental
health courts that we already have
existing
the next step i believe and a lot of us
are believing i think
is that
looking at standards is is the next
um is the next step so i look forward to
doing everything i can and we can in
grafton county to further that
progression and i thank you very much
for hearing me today i was asked um
one of our very
close collaborative collaborators chief
paul smith of the littleton police
department he did attempt to to um
he would like to speak today verbally if
you have the time he's on with us now
and thank you all very much
are there any questions from ms golden
first
yes representative langley
thank you mr chair for taking my
question and thank you miss goldberg um
i was wondering and this and this goes
back to the two previous bills that
we've also heard
people have talked about the um drug
courts and
and the advantage of having a
participant go back to complete high
school and also to get vocational
training could you help us understand is
that part of
what one could expect once they became
enrolled in that program and then the
second part the third part of that
question is also in terms of
reimbursement for the services that are
offered are most participants in the
drug court
program medicaid recipients thank you
thank you
first i would love to please um i love
this question i'll speak on behalf of
grafton county mental health court we do
tend to have a lot of similarities with
the other mental health courts in new
hampshire
so intensive case management through
community mental health
is targeted towards participants of
mental health court
and
in
with mental health court the individuals
we work with have severe and persistent
mental illnesses
they don't necessarily have to rise to
that level but that level does help
people
receive medicaid
and other insurance benefits that can
help them pay
for
the services that they needed to
including case management that leads to
you know helping people be connected to
um ged programs or
um vocational rehabilitation to help
people you know get back to work and
look um look at creating a job for
themselves um it made getting health
insurance to begin with um is huge we
keep we t we keep a look at those
statistics
it's a big part of what we do
and so all of those services under case
management
to help someone you know utilize already
existing resources in the community
to get themselves in a healthier place
is what we're looking for
thank you did i answer your questions
ma'am yes you did okay thank you very
much
any other
uh any other questions from ms golden
ms golden you said there's somebody else
there a police chief who wishes to speak
yes sir uh chief paul smith of the
littleton police department
and
is he going to be relatively brief in
his
we did we did talk about that our aim
was three minutes
or less so
well well
if mr if chief smith is right there
we'll let him speak if he could be aware
of our time limits today
i thank you for that sir chief smith is
in an interesting position he is on our
mental health court team but he's also
on our county's drug treatment corps
team okay we can hear from him now if
he's there
thank you
i apologize in um the
not uh scheduling appropriately but
thank you very much for your time and i
appreciate the sponsor um
of this particular bill i think it's an
outstanding bill
um
i don't want to rehash all of the
positive points
that
our previous speakers have presented to
you
i am a proponent of
both drug court mental health court i
sit on
both the grafton county superior court
drug court team and mental health court
team for grafton county for the
littleton circuit
and as well as the grafton county
advocates for mental health court
[Music]
law enforcement buy-in obviously uh is
is an issue with any um type of
alternative sentencing but i can tell
you that
my team
here in littleton and the surrounding
[Music]
towns within the district
all willfully participate in mental
health court uh it's a fantastic program
and as stated the recidivism rates are
um incredibly low
um which is one of the bigger factors as
far as a law enforcement perspective we
don't want to see repeat offenders
and we want them to regain a path to
wellness as well as citizenship
um being part of
g j smith i don't want to interrupt but
i don't think anybody is contesting
the value of the mental health court i
think the issue with this particular
bill
is whether or not there we should direct
the
chief justice of the supreme court to
come up with standards for a mental
health court and so
if you could
and i think it would be better if
everybody directed their testimony
toward
why do we need
standards as opposed to whether or not
there's value to the mental health court
because i think we all agree there is
i appreciate that representative gordon
and that's exactly why i want to speak
today
um i had the uh
the positive experience of meeting with
chief justice
uh both superior court and supreme court
as well as the administrative judge
for um
circuit courts
and my overall overall feeling
during the meeting was yes they were
accepted accepting mental health courts
but they felt that
uh it
there really wasn't a planned structure
for it in fact what i heard in our
meeting was is that he expected some
judges to volunteer time sometimes
during lunch
to
provide mental health court to the
participants there is no structure to
the program and i think that's one of
its biggest flaws
everybody has
worked very hard to make what we have
happen
but uh you know our my feeling in
grafton county is that if a clerk
doesn't want to um assist with the
program they simply don't allow us
access to the judge and there needs to
be structure and that's why i'm in
support of this bill and i appreciate
you getting right to the point the lack
of structure is preventing people from
accessing this program and preventing
its complete success throughout the
state for the citizens
and if i could just follow up on that
that mental health court is being done
in the circuit court is that right
that is correct
um
and just to follow up with that it's
focusing on individuals that are uh
their primary um
reason they're in that court is uh for
the mental health portion of it um which
is driving their criminal behavior uh
yes we have drug courts in in superior
court
which
the drug uses is driving that that
particular criminal behavior we do not
have mental health courts in superior
court which is another big issue and it
causes a huge kerfuffle when
we have somebody who wants to play in a
mental health court and superior court
level we just can't take them there's no
mechanism
to take them in the misdemeanor courts
and and that uh if i could just follow
up on that and that's part of what would
happen if you set standards
that would allow for that to happen
because right now the drug courts are in
the superior court the mental health
courts are in the circuit courts
absolutely sir uh yeah and there's two
different criteria for getting into them
there's uh different criteria for
getting into them and currently
i would say that all the mental health
courts in the state uh have different
criteria although they do have a
central focus uh each individual one has
different criteria
are there any other questions for chief
smith
thank you for testifying today
thank you so much
and we have robert oxley
good afternoon chairman and honorable
members of the committee
my name is bob oxley i'm the director of
field services for the department of
corrections
i'll be briefed with my comments uh this
afternoon as i've submitted written
testimony but wanted to emphasize a few
key points
department of corrections
considers this bill a wise investment
for the mental health community however
it would have to be an investment
if the mental health courts were to be
structured in the same way as the
current drug courts
this would have an impact on field
services without the improper
investment as mentioned in my written
testimony
these cases are very time consuming
and with proper funding we could meet
these goals
we would support this bill and would ask
we are involved in the process and
funded properly to be effective partners
with the proper investment
set standards would be a viable system
for the mental health community and the
division of field services could provide
the necessary work hours to make this as
successful in denver
i hope that was brief enough chairman
and i'm available for questions that was
great
are there any questions for mr oxley
seeing none thank you
much
it
and the next person is patrick ho
hello my name is patrick hoe i'm the
president of the new hampshire
psychiatric society and a board member
on the new hampshire medical society my
testimony today represents the new
hampshire psychiatric society as well as
the new hampshire medical society so
thank you chairman and honorable members
of the committee for allowing me to
speak today i had planned to cede most
of my time to um to jake barry on this
matter but do just want to make the
point that um of course the
incarceration is no substitute for
proper mental
health services and so i think that this
bill
is such an important bill for us to
consider and vote opt to pass
and as far as standards then i think
those would be very important for the
judiciary system to um to set because
having standards would allow us to
deliver deliver these services and
mental health courts um more
expeditiously and more efficiently and
allow us to reach more of those in need
so
i wanted to make myself available for
questions but did want to see most of my
time i appreciate the time today
thank you very much are any questions
for mr hall
again thank you for your testimony
the next
person is donna stamper
can you hear me now we can hear you
thank you so much for um letting us
speak today on this bill and i do stand
in very strong and hearty support
of standards based on a statewide
cooperation between judiciary and the
various programs that have sprung up and
are doing amazing work
in
parts of our state
um
i briefly wrote my written testimony so
i will try to be brief i just want to
say that absolutely
this
is key
to
validating that mental health courts and
mental health issues
are
important do valuable work save
taxpayers money
and
sometimes i mean i have been supportive
of the grafton county mental health
court um
from the beginning
as i said in my written testimony um
and
we need to validate this system and have
it organized and efficiently delivered
to
all the people across the state
thank you very much and i would hope
that you vote ought to pass
thank you very much for your testimony
are there any questions for ms stamper
yes hello good afternoon um again my
name is jill o'neill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i am in support of house bill
578. um i'm going to stick skip my
testimony and submit it in writing in
terms of the the background that i have
but i have extensive background in
supporting
and advancing the mental health court
and the greater nasha region alongside
judge leary
i'm also
have helped to set up the first veterans
behavioral health track and was invited
to capitol hill on behalf of senator
shaheen to talk about what we've been
doing in new hampshire so just to give
you some context about um you know my
expertise and as i give a point of
reference relative to the standards
um first and foremost i would highly
recommend that an advisory board be
established to conduct a thorough review
of each mental health court program in
new hampshire to understand the
landscape
the advisory board if enacted should be
comprised of key stakeholders
of experts with an understanding of the
10 essential elements of a mental health
court framework and the sequential
intercept model
i would caution that any independent
research or consultation by national
experts and proposing mental health
court standards be considered as part of
a final review and not the primary means
of establishing standards
and the purpose for this um
this theory is um to establish buy-in
from those key stakeholders ensure that
there's integrity there to the process
and this transparency
and what i've seen in these cases is
that when there's not transparency
within the process and the stakeholders
are engaged what it what the outcome is
is limited access
and in this situation the unintended
outcomes are shown from defendants who
are over sentenced to mental health
court where otherwise a least
restrictive sentence would be imposed or
the intended target population of
at-risk individuals are screened out
from participation and this negatively
impacts recidivism
outcomes and can jeopardize public
safety
you need reliable and meaningful data to
effectively run a program over the past
year i'm to serve as the co-facilitator
of the new hampshire justice involved
veterans task force and i've worked to
support veteran behavioral health tracks
with the task force by forging
partnerships with key stakeholders
to collect uniform data metrics for
analytics data analytics is critical to
the evaluation of any program or
organization
and if the advisory board were to be
established having data on the mental
health court programs would be crucial
to assessing the landscapes and lend
information about establishing statewide
standards for mental health courts
so you wouldn't implement a project
without a project lead
so i'm coming from business model and
also from a provider model
so we're having a statewide coordinator
of mental health courts that can be
shared to support not only the mental
health courts but the track that's off
of that which is supporting our justice
involved veterans through our veterans
behavioral health track is essential
new hampshire needs a strategic plan not
just standards a plan and i thank you
for your efforts in advancing this
conversation
this is necessary to enhance the current
existing programs and also to expand
your to jurisdictions without these
programs
absent this leadership
um this is the standards were likely if
imposed um could be risk at being
diluted and access to programming can be
impacted
a statewide coordinator can provide the
technical assistance provide ongoing
assessment of mental health court
programs and veteran track programs as
well coordinate trainings for the
ever-changing court and program
personnel
ensure equal access to mental health
court programs and be responsible for
statewide data analytics if we're going
to drive programs then we should be
responsible to share the data behind it
if you could just if you could just wrap
up your testimony
i've been at the helm of supporting the
sustainability of both the mental health
courts in the new hana new hampshire
veteran behavioral health tracks i will
submit my testimony in writing and i
urge you to read the testimony in
addition to judge leary
with our leadership and expertise of how
to advance this conversation and
initiatives forwards thank you very much
for your time
if i could just follow up on your
testimony you mentioned that there
needed to be a statewide coordinator and
i think there is a statewide coordinator
for the drug courts but not for the
mental health courts
if
if there needs to be a statewide and
you're looking at an advisory board are
you suggesting that we amend this bill
to do that or is that something that you
contemplate would be done
if we direct the chief justice to
adopt standards
um thank you for thank you for the
question and i i think that they're
if in reviewing of judge leary's
testimony and i know he submitted
written testimony i mean in the
testimony that i have today
i i would recommend that the the bill be
amended to ensure that there is uh
a process by which the standards are
developed
given some of the expertise that was
shared both in the written testimony my
testimony today
i guess if i had one more question
and you know i'm well aware that judge
leary has a wonderful reputation for
running the mental health court down in
nashua
but
has he made any efforts
through judge king to already do this on
a circuit court basis
without necessarily having to get the
supreme court involved
so there's been a lot of conversations
um and great initiatives but we need
coordination to drive these you know
changes um suggested or proposed changes
and and and that's where i come in
through the veterans behavioral health
track i can share that we have national
justice for um
a national organization that already we
don't need to recreate the wheel this
has already been established
my efforts because there's no statewide
coordination are not successful it's
taking an exorbitant amount of time so
it's not just
establishing the standards or the the
procedure it's about somebody that
drives it having somebody responsible
that oversees and and
and helps execute the project plan
essentially
the questions
from ms o'neill
yes representative langley
representative langley you're muted i
think
apologize thank you for letting me know
miss o'neill i thought when i when
um this bill was first presented i was
very clear
and i guess the longer our discussion
goes the murkier it is getting for me
i'm not understanding why
the system
uh both the judicial the mental health
and medical have not collaborated
together and and
developed the standards taking on their
own initiative at this point
can you help me realize why that hasn't
happened
thank you representative langley um so i
i think that uh there has been a lot of
collaboration but that exists within
each individual jurisdiction and um so i
know that there's statewide coordination
through alex casill the statewide drug
court coordinator and also the mental
health court liaisons but who's the
responsible party
who's responsible to set that up and
that leads me back to why it's
imperative that we establish a statewide
coordinator
follow-up mr chair certainly
so
really what you're talking about is the
leadership of the project as well as the
authority to really uh set the
implementation
within multiple agencies
that is correct representative langley
thank you
any other questions
ms o'neill
xenon thank you for your testimony today
thank you
and patrick dowling
patrick is there
not sure i see him on the list of
attendees
and don tonkin
and i'm not sure i see
and rachel canterbury
that was easy
and
i see
judge nadeau his hand up here
judge nadeau would you like to speak
yes thank you i i was afraid that maybe
i hadn't signed up correctly but i i
really appreciate the time and the
opportunity to hear everybody and i will
be very brief and focus on your question
about standards and i do think it's
important to have standards i think that
when the legislature funded fully funded
drug courts we were able to have the
resources
to
make sure we were implementing standards
there are as i said in the previous
hearing national standards for drug
courts there aren't any for mental
health courts for all kinds of reasons i
think
the national folks just didn't want they
didn't have the time and and energy to
put into another whole set of standards
so there are some states that have
developed standards that we could take a
look at
and i do think judge king and i were
both on the commission that produced
this legislation so he and i are talking
together all the time we do have a drug
court coordinator and i think having an
office that addresses the specialty
courts with various participants so
they're working together but also having
their own specialty make some sense and
these standards would be able to address
all of those things judge leary has been
an incredible leader in the mental
health courts and they even though we
have drug courts and mental health
courts drug courts are designed to deal
with co-occurring issues so mental
health and treatment but the main
problem is substance use mental health
courts also deal with co-occurring
issues but the main problem is a
persistent mental health issue so there
is room for both and i think when we
have
best practice standards to follow then
we're going to make sure we have the
best outcomes
for judge nadeau
i think i had this is sort of a process
question
and that is
can the legislature direct the chief
justice of the supreme court to do
something in being a separate branch of
government
right
i understand that the
circuit court is a creation of the
legislature and we
have authority to do the design
over the circuit court
but i guess the question i had was can
we direct the chief justice to take some
particular action
wow you really put me on the hot spot
right so i i you know i always want to
respect the balance between the two
branches and work collaboratively
and you know when you're talking um
straight up can one branch order another
branch to do something probably not but
we we all want to cooperate in this
effort and make sure that we're we're
using resources wisely and i think that
judge king understands the value i mean
he and i spoke before this testimony the
value of mental health courts he's
gotten some really great judges in the
circuit court to be leaders so whatever
you decide we are we know that it's
important to you to come up with
standards and we'll get it done
you any other questions for
chief justice
see none
thank you for your testimony today
thank you
and i see alex cassell is asked to
testify as well
hi can you hear me
we can all right thank you um thank you
mr chairman and members of the committee
i will be very brief i just wanted to
touch on a couple points that people had
brought up over the course of this
hearing uh i'm testifying on behalf of
or in support of house bill 578 i am the
statewide coordinator um the technical
term is the drug offender program
coordinator um but essentially i oversee
the drug courts so we are currently
working on a strategic plan with some
federal partners bja has a technical
assistance grant that they've given to
center for court innovations out of new
york um we're currently working on that
and mental health court is going to be
part of that plan
um we also secured a master's level
intern from unh who this will be her
primary project will to be to do some
national research and local research on
our mental health courts to help us
craft uh potentially statewide standards
if this bill is passed
and then
the the reason for this or that i feel
that is very necessary
one of the questions you asked earlier
with about
chiefs to chief smith was
um i need to be able to walk into a
courtroom and recognize them in a mental
health court if we have no standards
they can all look very different and
we're only going to be judged on
the you know the the worst
performing mental health court and if
they're not following the standards
then we can turn to that court and say
well you need to follow standards six
seven and eight you're not doing that so
that's the new that's the basis of the
need for standards is to make sure that
they're all operating properly and
if you walk into any courtroom during a
mental health court session you'll
recognize where you are
thank you
thank you any questions for mr cassell
representative smith
thank you very much um
i i'm not even sure how to ask this
question
what
i hear is that
the judicial branch
cares a lot about many of the same
things that many members of the
legislature care about
um
but
they
seem not to have
the
understanding of how to
structure
their courts
and
we are
so regularly resisted and rebuffed
when we in the legislature try to make
suggestions to the courts
about things that we think are important
i can't quite understand
why
the roles have been reversed and
the courts don't seem to find the
resources to do this and need us to tell
them what to do
that's a long question mr chair but it's
because i'm really befuddled
um thank you for your question i think
that that question might
well be beyond my scope uh to answer if
judgmental is still on she may be able
to answer that but i i will just say
this one thing to to your question
hopefully it will help address it which
is
i think that the court system in terms
of this legislative piece of legislation
was was ready
to come up with standards we were at
that point in in the
in the process we created the statewide
drug courts um
you know on the
after the legislation was passed we
focused on that and that and now we're
looking to move beyond the adult drug
courts because we want to also encompass
some of our other treatment courts that
we have in the state
so i don't know if that answers your
question but that's i think that's the
best i can i can come up with on the
spot
is he judging the vote judge nadeau has
her hand up perhaps she would like to
weigh in
oh thank you i just want to make sure i
offered that in case you wanted to ask
me ask me you know was it just in 2016
where the legislature
believed it was appropriate to fully
fund drug courts so that's been about
four years we've had one drug court
coordinator who's put a ton of effort
into making sure we're following
standards there we have incredibly
amount of dedicated judges and community
leaders who are forging ahead with
mental health courts even though we
didn't really have the resources to do
that so those mental health courts are
operating well and now we've been able
to turn our attention to what can we do
to make sure they're operating more
consistently and one of the steps is to
come up with standards the commission
that meant last year started to go down
the road of describing what they should
all look like and they were very
receptive to
our suggestion that we come up with
standards first and because there are no
national standards that made it
challenging as well so we are all in
and representative smith did you have a
follow-up question
well um i have such admiration
for uh judge nedo and for the incredible
work that she's done here and work that
she's done in other areas i go all the
way back to senate bill 500
um
i'm just not clear on whether the
problem is that the
judiciary that the governor has not um
identified appropriate funds
or that the legislature has not agreed
to appropriate funding um
or
and that is and as a result the staff is
not
of the size and experience it should be
um i i just am not clear on where the
boundaries are and i want to respect the
boundaries between the judicial and the
legislative
branches
i guess i would say i just don't i don't
think there's a problem i think there is
concerted effort on all parts to
to move forward and recognize that
standards would be appropriate
if i could just
follow up on that
and
it seems that there was a time in the
circuit court where
uh
we opened up the idea that it made lots
of sense to have mental health courts
and then
we sort of went through the recessionary
period and began in 2008
and it seems like there haven't
been enough circuit court judges
or they all appear to be
the ones that are there
seem to be very busy
yeah and
as a result
um even though there is a
wonderful intent on the part of lots of
people to do more i think many feel that
they just don't have the resources or
the ability to do more
and i guess the question is
will creating standards actually
provide the resources you need to get
the job done
no you're you're online am i there oh
sorry i'm so sorry i'm so not used to
this
no i think you said it absolutely well
um
uh representative gordon it it it does
take a lot of time to run these courts
when we when we got drug courts up and
running we figured it was probably a
full-time equivalent of a judge and a
half but we didn't ask for it because we
had already been asking for so much so
and then when you talk about all the
circuit courts and that's really mostly
where these mental health court cases
come up
they have a hard time fitting into that
into their incredibly busy busy docket
so there's two things there's standards
so we can know what it's going to look
like then we'll know what the resource
requirement is and then there's the
resource issue and that so i think
you've got the history absolutely right
any other questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
again today thank you
i did um
there was somebody who signed up it was
shannon bader
and i don't know if she wished to
testify or not
yes
i think you're muted
can you hear me now we can
hi my name is shannon bader i'm a
psychologist from beau new hampshire and
i just wanted to
highlight a couple points i'm a forensic
psychologist who's licensed here in new
hampshire
so i conduct psychological evaluations
for all district and superior courts
for folks who have mental illness
throughout the state
so i've had a front row seat to all the
jurisdictions the ones that have mental
health court and the ones that do not
and in addition to my role as a forensic
psychologist i'm also the
president-elect of the american academy
of forensic psychologists so this has
given me a chance to look at the
nationwide trends in mental health
courts across the country
and i wanted to just say a couple things
about standards and also about
collaboration here in new hampshire
um i had three points i wanted to go
over the first is that mental health
court works i think you've heard enough
about that today
the second point though is about
standards that
i think a bill that supports standards
will help new hampshire develop
standards that are unique for our state
so
there's many different kinds of mental
health courts some focus only on
felonies others focus only on
misdemeanors
mental health courts that are focused on
just state-specific goals state-specific
priorities that would fit our existing
mental health system and fit our
existing drug court system is why this
bill is important so having a a
state-bound set of standards is what we
really need
and then i think a statewide approach is
also necessary as you're seeing we have
sort of a piecemeal approach at this
point
there is a lot of collaboration in new
hampshire but it's by jurisdiction
most often it's different counties or
different
specific areas of the state that are
working together but as a state-wide
approach this will allow us to make sure
that just as they were saying about drug
courts that this the mental health court
up in stratford county will look the
same as the mental health court in
hillsborough county
and more importantly right now coast
county doesn't have one so as for
example someone in my role i have to
remember that there are different
options available to different
defendants throughout the state
i find this generally unfair
and i think is a statewide approach that
it's one of those times where the rising
tide will raise all ships that as long
as we have a statewide approach
then every county will be able to speak
the same language
and be able to address these complicated
issues in the same way
so as this is having a statewide
approach will be especially useful when
there has been collaboration across
counties but then we'll bring in more
counties into this conversation
uh that's all i have to offer today but
i just want to thank you all for your
service to our state
thank you ms vader any questions from
his vader
see none thank you very much
and i don't see any other hands up
and so i'm going to declare the hearing
on house bill 578 closed
and call to order
the hearing on our last bill today which
is house bill 561.
i will note that
with regard to the sign up sheets nobody
signed up in support
nobody signed up in opposition
and no one signed up to testify
um
a
bill's uh primary and only sponsors
representative cofo and
i don't know if representative cofold
yeah
he's here
so representative cofoult if you'd like
to introduce your bill this is a bill
relative to potential jurors excused
from jury duty due to a lack of
residency in the county of jury service
thank you mr chairman um so this this is
quite a simple bill
this bill is about voter integrity and
the
you know the the
the driving force behind this i think is
is the idea that
uh citizen involvement is vital to good
government and that includes visibility
to government proceedings and records
as
specified in part 1 article 8 of the new
hampshire constitution
today there is a great deal of attention
focused on election integrity
in many cases it is the citizen
activists who are
tracking down
questionable cases and irregularities
this bill provides visibility as to who
may be registered to vote in new
hampshire
but later claims not to live in new
such cases do not indicate primophasia
evidence of illegal voting however it
does help
someone who is trying to identify such
cases to identify potential voting
irregularities so that they can be
investigated further
so this is a small tool in a much
much larger
toolbox
citizens have a right to investigate
potential issues of voting irregularity
and they should have an opportunity to
do so by examining government records
part one article eight of the new
hampshire constitution states government
therefore should be open accessible
accountable and responsive
to that end the public's right of access
to governmental proceedings and records
shall not be unreasonably restricted
this bill would make sure that
the the records concerning who has
who has asked to be excused from jury
duty
for lack of residence in the county in
which they are asked to serve
that those records be made available to
the public and for this reason i ask
that you support hb 561
with a recommendation ought to pass
thank you and representative oregon do
you have a question
he actually
answered answered my first question
right there in the uh first sentence
that this is about uh
about what he referred to as voter
integrity i might use a different uh
word after voters like this is indeed to
try to find uh
this is indeed try to uh trying to chase
voters who uh
may or may not have moved out of their
county so that's uh thank you for
answering that revenue call faulty
other new other question is why is it
how many
how many people is this going to catch
and um like why
and uh why is it every six months
instead of you know
on a rolling basis and um
[Music]
also is
being uh she's for jury duty is that's
something that's normally a public
record i was i've been excused from jury
duty actually ironically because of my
service on the judiciary committee but i
don't
i don't recall whether or not they said
that was confidential not that i would
have had any problem with being telling
people excuse for that reason so that's
uh
why so that's those are my two specific
questions they asked why every six
months instead on continued basis and uh
like
and
are people who have
chief and jury duty regularly have their
names made public or is this an
exception to that
uh so to the first question um i think
that doing it every six months uh
relieves the uh the state of an
excessive um
an excessive administrative burden it
makes it actually quite easy i think to
to report those names to the secretary
of state and for the secretary of state
to publish them
and
as to the second question
i'm not aware that
such names are currently
considered to be
confidential or public uh this just
merely would make them public make it
public that that people have asked to be
excused
yeah yeah one question
presumably uh
filing period i guess probably was after
the election and as you know we had a
very protracted uh
a very uncommitted transition power so
do you think the events of uh
they came between uh on november 6th i
guess with the date last year and
january
20th this is a rise in january
that give you
even any second thought about whether or
not this bill or anything that makes it
harder for
people to vote is a good idea like do
you think this
those events make this fellowship more
necessary to you less that's necessary
or does it have no effect
i
don't believe that this makes it harder
for any to anyone to vote in any way
whatsoever um i had not i don't believe
this is about
any any recent events per se i do
believe that there's quite a lot of
interest in this topic right now
but i think this is a necessary bill
whether it happens now or
five years ago or five years from now
where is that lorenzo
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative kobalt
um
i was a little puzzled when i
read this bill because i did not see the
word vote anywhere in the bill
um
that's just a comment and now i have a
question i've been living in new
hampshire for 28 years i've been called
the jury duty once
so i'm
really
wondering if this bill is really needed
thank you
thank you for your question
representative uh so
so i i too have been called once in the
time that i have lived in new hampshire
which is i think less than the time
you've lived here
uh but i uh you know to to me this this
is not necessarily a question about the
frequency at which people are called to
serve
um you know it to me this is this is
fundamentally a question about
um
you know providing another tool to uh to
to understand um who is registered to
vote but not
serving jury duty as i said before
that that may or may not be evidence uh
you know it really isn't
prime prime aphasia evidence of of
something being wrong but it is one tool
in a much larger toolbox so do i believe
that this will um sort of open the
floodgates to discovering all kinds of
malfeasance no
do i think that it will be a tool that
could be used by citizens to ensure
election integrity yes
representative smith
thank you very much i'm a little
confused the bill came to judiciary and
i assume it's because of
um
jury service
but the testimony
has all been not about jury service but
about voting
and um
so i i wonder why i didn't go to
election law
and um
while we're at it i'd like to say that
i've never been called for jury service
and i very much would have liked to have
been called and i'm wondering if there
might be a way to
to investigate why some of us don't get
called to jury service even when we live
in the county
thank you
is that a question
well
yes i mean why is this
do you not see this as an election law
problem rather than a
judiciary committee problem
i i uh thank you representative i would
i would defer to to house leadership um
as they are the ones that assigned this
to uh to the the judiciary committee
um you know i i i'm guessing that it's
because it pertains to
the publication of information
on people who were selected as potential
jurors
um to your second point for what it's
worth i i i fully agree with you i i
would be very interested in uh better
understanding uh how that process works
and and why some people are chosen and
some are not um i personally was chosen
for a very high profile criminal case
and you know it was it was a it was a
an insightful opportunity to see how the
system works so
it was really i think a pleasure to uh
to be part of that
thank you very much for your response
appreciate it
perhaps we could arrange for it to go to
a second committee
are there any other
representative gordon
yes if i may um you know just to point
out that you know it did go to judiciary
because
quite frankly we didn't have a crystal
ball to know that this was going to lead
to
a bill about
voter integrity
so um
you know and i don't see the word vote
voting any or elections anywhere in the
bill so i imagine that's why it was sent
to judiciary
i i don't think you need to be defensive
i think i i can see the why it was sent
to judiciary based on its face and
uh but
perhaps
it could go to a second committee and in
some in some manner i think we've missed
the deadline on that represent mr
chairman we have this year
yes
i mean you could always retain the bill
and
send it to a second committee next year
that's another possibility
representative oregon
yes
um i have a second question so thank you
for accommodating mr chair thank you
very cold fault um
why
why did you limit it to just that uh one
reason since there's any number of
reasons why people excuse me jury duty
and
mandate having a list of everyone who's
excused from jury duties so then you can
cross-check that list against voter
rolls in order of your attempts to catch
people who
are vote voting in the wrong place
that
that's my question
well i i you're talking about why did i
why does the bill say for lack of
being excused for lack of residence is
that
your question okay um because lack of
residence would indicate a um a a
um
a lack of domicile in that uh
in that in that county
which may indicate a lack of um of of
the right to vote it also may not um you
know they may have moved to a different
part of new hampshire
they also may be an overseas voter
so if you're in the military or
otherwise
overseas you
have a right to vote from your last new
hampshire
address so you can remain registered to
vote
from your last new hampshire address so
the fact that somebody is registered to
vote and indeed is still voting
but has asked to be excused from jury
duty for lack of of residence in
the county where they're registered
again is not private prime aphasia
evidence that there's anything wrong
all right thank you
any other questions for
uh representative
i don't see any
thank you for your testimony today
thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify today
signed up if you
you are among the attendees and wish to
testify just raise your hand
seeing no one will close the hearing
on house bill 561.
representative sylvia did you have a
question
uh sorry not about that i was waiting
for you to uh close that hearing i just
want to do alert members that i have an
amendment for a bill we're going to hear
on friday
and get to it in your email before it
gets buried
any any other business to attend to this
afternoon
if not thanks everybody for your your
patience today and we'll
see you on friday i'm not sure we'll
have everybody on friday so it's not my
intent to exec anything on friday
but
but please either plan to be here
next tuesday or have a substitute
available so we can get our bills out
anyway thank you so much
y'all
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you mr chairman mr chairman